e
for being here on a Friday afternoon we
appreciate that um we have a couple
of uh we have uh three of our members
are currently at a county delegation
meeting and will be uh here later um so
we will take no official actions on any
bills um until we have a quorum uh if we
do take any official actions
today uh just a another quick
announcement um in the announcement for
this subcommittee meeting uh HB 608 was
listed um that was an inadvertent error
administratively we won't say who made
the error um but it was already exec and
so we will not be reviewing that any
further under the committee we
may um mention it in the context of
another bill perhaps but but it will not
be reviewed or acted on by the
subcommittee
then uh I think I will wait on any more
announcements until the rest of the
subcommittee gets here but uh what I'd
like to do at this moment is um discuss
Bill HB
289 it is Rel regarding uh domicile
and um I was uh informed that
our uh friends from the ACLU Mr Clement
totz uh H has um a few uh comments
pertinent to this bill and so he
graciously agreed to come up and testify
on that at this time so um Mr Clement
tonas I invite you to come forward and
feel free to uh speak to House Bill 289
it is um it has a
few aspects to it um talking about
whether or not domicile might be claimed
if someone is a legal dependent under
custody at an address outside the state
of New Hampshire and um has some
other
uh aspects uh regarding domicile and
residency as well and uh just for those
listening
um just be reminded that domicile is is
essential to voting in New Hampshire you
must have domicile in New Hampshire to
vote um and you also are once you do
make such a
declaration either through registration
or voting you must fulfill the residency
requirements as well but also advise
people that you can have uh multiple
residencies s such as some of our
snowbirds have um and so with that sort
of brief introduction I invite Mr
Clement totz to provide us with your
usual insightful testimony if you would
please well thank you so much for the
record my name is Henry clemento I'm the
deputy legal director at the American
civil liberties of Union of New
Hampshire I want to start with uh
expressing my profound appreciation for
the subcommittee for allowing me to
testify at this time um just very
greatly
appreciated so I I have a few remarks
that I'm going to keep pretty short um I
think that there's two and I'm going to
talk just about the changes requ uh
about legal dependents who are claim can
be claimed outside of the state and so I
think there's two issues with this that
I wanted to raise for the subcommittee
one constitutional and one
practical so the the first
constitutional issue is that um it's
really not so I understand this bill to
be talking about when that uses the word
dependent to be talking about that from
a tax perspective in that um because I'm
not aware of that being used throughout
the New Hampshire statutes otherwise so
I understand it to
be if if a person is claimed on the
taxes of their parents as a
dependent um and those parents reside
outside the state that the person won't
have domicile in New Hampshire even if
they otherwise meet the qualifications
and so from a constitutional perspective
the problem I see is that you are
conditioning someone else's right to
vote on the actions of another which is
their parents and it's not up to like
when I was a child my parents I think
claimed me on their taxes as a dependent
I don't know whether that continued when
I was throughout college but it wasn't
up to me they didn't discuss it with me
and so if my right to vote were
dependent on them claiming me as a
dependent for taxes or
not I think that's that's an
unconstitutional condition to put on
someone else's right to vote because the
other qualifications that we talk about
in terms of domicile are really within a
person's control so you choose to live
within New Hampshire to establish a
physical presence and you choose to make
it your primary place for engaging in
Civic self-government but in in essence
what this is doing is giving your
parents a veto over whether you can vote
in New Hampshire so say for example a
person you know were a registered
Republican and wanted to vote for
candidate a went to college in New
Hampshire but their parents were
Democrats and didn't want their child
voting in New Hampshire they could stop
them from doing that by claiming them on
their taxes under this bill and so I
think that's an
unconstitutional condition from a
practical perspective I think it's in
some way this is in some ways even a
bigger issue in so far as tax returns
are confidential by Statute and so
there's no way of anyone knowing as far
as I'm aware whether the has happened or
not so if I wanted to know whether my
parents claimed me as a dependent I'd
have to ask them they're under no
obligation to tell me they could tell me
the truth or not and unless I you know
were able to somehow subpoena their tax
records I I'd be sort of at a loss as to
whether or not I am in fact claimed as a
dependent because I don't as a minor or
as a dependent necessarily have access
to their taxes in addition
the state authorities wouldn't
necessarily either they may I mean the
Dr will have access if the person is
paying New Hampshire taxes although we
don't have an income tax anymore but the
Dr or or or the Attorney General's
office or the supervisors of the
checklist are not going to have access
to the parents IRS
returns and so there's no way for that
to be enforced either and so you're kind
of putting the potential voter in a
catch 22 of they can ask their parents
whether they're being claimed they can
ask their parents not to claim them and
Sort of hope that their
parents don't claim them if asked or
respond or respond truthfully but sort
of like actually meeting with your
parents accountant and getting them to
wave confidentiality there's nothing
that the voter can do to ensure that
they're voting lawfully because they may
not know and there's really no way for
the state to know whether the person is
voting lawfully either because they're
not going to have access to the parents
tax returns and if the parents are
residing out of state as I'm saying this
I'm real ing they're not going to be
paying New Hampshire income taxes anyway
they're going to be paying another
State's taxes and so there wouldn't be
Dr records so those are the the the
issues as I see them they're sort of the
Constitutional issue of conditioning a
person's right to vote on the actions of
their parents and then the Practical
issues of like all this is confidential
and how does anyone know so those are my
concerns um again I really appreciate so
much the actions of the chair and the
full subcommittee for allowing me to
testify um and I'm happy to take any
questions if there are any thank you Mr
Clementon
uh representative Burnham do you have
time thank you Mr chair I I I appreciate
the explanation
um I I don't have any questions at this
time though thank
you uh thank you I if
um I I do have some questions for and
now it seems like the perfect time to
mention that I am not a tax attorney
right and right okay and so um I will do
my best to answer but people should not
for be operating under the illusion that
I know anything about taxes in looking
around the room I do not see any tax
attorney so I think we're all in good
company uh no offense to tax attorneys
but um so let me just ask uh this
um if if the person is here in New
Hampshire is truly a dependent and is
only um here under the sustenance of the
uh parent or
Guardian um and they are in fact
controlling that person being here by
that sustaining resources does that
change your opinion on any of
this so it's a it's it's a great
question and I think the answer is no
what I'm thinking as I'm speaking so I'm
going to do my best um so
first I don't I'm not as I said a tax
expert and so I'm not sure if that's
really what's required for person to be
claimed as a dependent under the tax
code
um I did a little bit of brief research
and it if I if I may I I'm again I'm not
a tax person but I believe it the law or
the language on the tax forms is
something of supplying more than 50% of
the wherewithal you know or equivalent
for a person so if they're in fact if
that person is in fact living in New
Hampshire and the parents or Guardian
are living elsewhere then um you know
and now especially with be because of
the health care uh through the
Affordable Care Act the requirement to
support Health Care coverage up through
age
26 right um so those those aspects I
think come to bear on this so again I'm
to Echo your your Sage words I am not a
tax accountant but I am familiar with
those aspects and so uh a a person who
is a dependent is ostensibly yeah uh
more than 50% supported and I I think it
would be
reasonably I think it would be logical
to conclude that in fact their ability
to to be in New Hampshire in a place
separate from their parents and
Guardians and with the parents and
Guardians also claiming them as a
dependent again some coordination needs
to and communication needs to occur in
order to have that but in in fact that
person is here on valtion of the parent
or Guardian so so yeah what does what
are your insights onto that so A few
things so um I think a common scenario
of people that we're talking about who
are voting age who could be claimed for
their are students and I think that
there are special tax rules for choosing
students and so I think a common
Arrangement it involves a student and
parents co-signing loans for tuition is
a
frequent um and so whether that is
enough of a financial contribution to
claim someone as a dependent I don't
know but the student is still taking on
significant debt in order to to pay
their own way and so typically people
who are in New Hampshire to be in school
are doing that are financing that and so
whether they're doing that with the
assistance of their parents or no um I
think that's part so that that's part of
it number two um you know most of us are
existing in in New Hampshire at the
sustenance of somebody whether it's our
parents or our employers and I think
that there's a slippery slope between
saying you know your parents are paying
for you to be here and so you don't have
the same full rights of citizenship
because your parents live out of state
instead of you know maybe you're
remotely working for a company that's
headquartered outside of the state and
they're paying for you there's obviously
differences but I but but I think that
that's a um a road that we don't want to
travel down is looking at the financial
wherewithal of New Hampshire voters
because some people who vote in New
Hampshire have no means to speak of and
um and and so I'm you know and given the
history of voting in this country I'm in
particular look a scance at the idea of
trying to inquire into the financial
respects of people but I I'll note that
in general the New Hampshire domicile
definition has never inquired as to
where your assets come from it's really
about do you have a physical presence in
the state and is it your home for
participation in Democratic
self-government and how you get there or
not you know where your money comes from
has never before been a test for the
domicile requirement and so this would
be something new you know I understand
that it
is uh Ju Just if I may interject that uh
one of the uh proofs of evidence of
docility or if that's the right word of
domicile um can be a tax form that has a
New Hampshire address so there is that
connection I I didn't want you to forget
that but um but uh so it's not
completely unique or or out of it it's
not like it hasn't intruded into the
election law discussion before but it's
an excellent point that you're making I
mean a tax form is a government document
with your address on it and so I think I
look at that as proof of physical
presence um more than as participation
in Democratic self-government in the
state because you may be paying you know
New Hampshire income taxes if you work
in the state but live in Massachusetts
for example if we still had income taxes
that may be the case you would be paying
New Hampshire property taxes if you own
a second home in the state regardless of
whether it's your primary domicide um so
I've always thought of that more as
proof of the physical presence but I but
I but I take your point um and so I
think that's probably the best job that
I can do answering your question and
then of course there's the issue of like
what if a parent claims someone as a do
you know as a dependent on their tax
returns either mistakenly or
fraudulently thinking that they're
providing half of the person's assets
but in fact they're not I'm not sure
that the you know that the statute as
written really contemplates that I mean
it says legal dependent sure but I'm I'm
not sure that it does and then you have
that if there were ever an enforcement
action you're going to have to prove up
everyone's assets and bring in forensic
accountants to do that in it I I'm not
plausible it it does it does seem to be
uh
following it to that extreme
uh does seem to be Beyond The Pale but I
I again you're you're laying out a whole
sequence of events there at that point
that's my job um all right
so
um I don't have any other questions at
this time I want to thank you very much
for your testimony and we were able to
get you out of here uh before your court
appearance yes thank you so much and
I'll just reiterate that if anyone on
the subcommittee has any questions about
anything I'm always available uh thank
you um I'll I'll let the other remaining
subcommittee uh members know that and
and that goes for committee staff as
well oh thank you appreciate that all
right thank you so
luck all right um at this time
um I'd like to welcome Mr Richard Daniel
Richard to oh I'm sorry did you uh yes
Mr
O'Brien thank you very much Mr chair uh
for the record my name is Michael
O'Brien lobbyist with pry strategies uh
and representing America votes um I just
want to
um to bring up the second part which is
the attachment of of uh UNH um residency
and state tuition standards to uh and
just read their definition for you just
so we're all clear um a students's
resident for tuition purposes is
considered to be that of their parent
unless the student is emancipated to
qualify for Interstate tuition status a
student or his her parents if a
dependent must physically reside in New
Hampshire for no less than 12 continuous
months prior to the term for which the
estate status is desired must reside in
New Hampshire for some purpose other
than attending the university and meet
all the requirements for tuition rules I
also want to stress that in the
beginning um it talks about how they
they apply this standard at the as a
freshman so you can't you know this
isn't this doesn't get Revisited uh you
you can't actively try to if they change
it so what you're saying is if they if
the student were to change that in you
know from their sophomore to junior year
it would it's they're still obligated as
I as I read it the website says
residency is determined at the time of
admission for a degree ah so to not to
regate everything that attorney Clement
Tois just said but uh this again goes
back to dependency right as was stated
in that definition that it depends on
where your dependents live not
necessarily where you live and also
again you could very well establish um
yourself in in New Hampshire over the
four years but because this is set at
the first year um you know you would
never qualify under and obviously there
are lots of constitutional problems if I
lived in a place for four years and was
told that I couldn't vote but more than
that all of the definitions made up here
um 12 months to qualify and all these
other things are longer uh establishment
periods than contained within voting
rights law so I just wanted to share
that with the committee make sure we
understood what the definition was yes
thank you that's very helpful of course
appreciate
all right Mr Richard are you ready I am
as ready as I'm going to be today how
are you all right very well thank you
today we had uh
just uh for awareness that Mr Richard uh
has spoken uh previously to the full
election law committee and after hear
ing your testimony there um multiple
members um it was a bipartisan interest
um we're interested in hearing you come
today and speak
on
um various aspects that this uh
subcommittee is looking at so
glasses that that's uh
what power multiple places because of
the wind yeah
delay all right so glad it didn't affect
me other than printing yeah so is this a
quorum it it doesn't uh you missed that
part it doesn't have to be a quorum
until uh if unless we make an official
action on a specific
bill so um let me let me uh give you the
option is it sounds
like
um if you have the time I'm completely
flexible I'm here to be till close we
could take a brief recess for a few
minutes and allow more members to get
here perfect um let me uh if you'll
if uh the
other members will be coming here as
well I I just got a message from one
person that they would be leaving in
five minutes and that's appro they would
now so let me just uh check into that
but what I what I would suggest they're
they're reportedly about uh 10 minutes
away so so I would suggest maybe taking
a brief
recess
until
um 10 of and then that would all that
would allow us to do um some things
again uh one of my favorite sayings is
blessed are the flexible they will not
be broken so we will uh adhere to that
motto and um we will be flexible and
we'll recess until 10 minutes before two
and they'll reconvene and begin to hear
Mr Richard's testimony and that'll allow
me also an opportunity to speak with Mr
Allen so thank you very much we'll be
minutes
e
for your Indulgence with
a uh County delegate there are some
members of the subcommittee who had a
county delegation obligation and
therefore could not attend until just
now um I want to thank Mr Richards for
your patience with our subcommittee and
um we will at this time begin and um I
want to welcome you and thank you uh for
appearing again I will note that uh
several members of the subcommittee had
heard Mr Richard speak during the full
election law committee proceedings uh
during a public hearing and uh had
expressed interest to me about hearing
Mr Richard speak further on some of his
topics and
accordingly um uh based on those
requests I've invited Mr Richard to come
and speak before the subcommittee um if
I could um just also if I could um if I
could just request um that uh people in
the room not talk during testimony
please
um
and uh so
at U Mr Richard I invite you
to uh go ahead and speak um we may have
one more member who arrive and he may
have to traes behind you but uh we ask
for your Indulgence with that as well
blue is microphone or red is
hot awesome thank you so much um wrote
it all down in case that way he'll be
able to get to catch up to speed uh
again let's start over um good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen chairman honorable
members of the committee thank you for
the opportunity to testify here before
you today my name is Daniel Richard I'm
a citizen of New Hampshire I'm
inhabitant of Auburn and those words
citizen of state and inhabitant will
become very important as we continue on
and uh I'm grateful for this invitation
and opportunity to share with you my 10
plus years of study and knowledge of
these very important election law issues
now before the subcommittee
and the election law committee as a
whole I want to share with the committee
my personal story as an example of some
of the relevant election issues we're
here to talk about today the election
issues before us today should remain
nonpartisan as they are as they affect
all of us full disclosure I'm a
registered Republican and I vote
Republican unfortunately all the named
defendants in my case are Republicans
because they fail to obey their Oath by
refusing to follow the Constitution the
this does not make me very popular with
the Republican
party uh of the past the sad reality is
everyone in government this is important
everyone in government today did not
create the problems we're here to
discuss but rather We inherited these
election changes by Design when all the
previous election laws were codified 46
years ago in
1979 under the previous Secretary of
State Bill Gardner the ACT codified 195
years years of new H New Hampshire
election law by a single act and is now
our current election statutes that's how
they all came to be along with other
changes since that's a huge load that
they took upon themselves think about it
to consolidate 195 years all in one act
and so that was 436 colon one was the
act and I have copies as part of these
part of the records I've given
everyone and so um it's impossible for
anyone to be perfect so the fact that
there are uh um issues that W properly
sorted out when the recodification
happened is is not a huge problem uh in
this respect one of the Geniuses of our
state constitution is the ability to
alter the document and they found that
out very early in our history in 1776
where that was what was wrong with our
January 1776 Constitution there was no
way to amend the document but they would
go on to draft the one that we had have
today after three constitutional
conventions and so the one we work with
today of 1784 has been amended ever
since and
um the uh in my case for those of you
who don't know um I currently have a
case that has went all the way to the
Supreme Court on Election law it's been
remanded to the trial court I'll expound
on that in in in a lot of specificity
because it had deals specifically with
the affidavit questions that I raised
when I testified last time and I looked
to clarify them today um the the issue
is as I said the problem isn't that uh
that they C that the people that I filed
suit against were they didn't physically
cause the problems it's the cover up
it's the refusal to address the issue I
did in fact use the constitutional right
to redress our grievances by
remonstrance by giving everyone involved
notice from the Secretary of State to
the governor to the attorney general to
my local municipality everyone had
notice and they chose rather than
address any of the issues they I had no
choice but to go down through the legal
process so that it's been entertaining
to say the
least
uh needless to say today I'm very
pleased to finally have an opportunity
before this committee to address these
issues so thank you again my background
I was born outside of the United States
200 miles from here in Canada my parent
parents applied for and were granted
visas thereby establishing their legal
status as lawful resident alien which
allowed my parents to reside permanently
in New Hampshire as a permanent resident
legal alien a green card holder this
will become important as we try to us
deal with these issues of defining who a
qualified voter is and I think my
personal experience will expound upon
that I was naturalized in 1981 at the
Hillsboro County Superior Court in
Manchester under state and federal
immigration laws which run parallel to
each other under state and federal
jurisdiction my naturalization
certificate defines me as a citizen of
the United States of America which also
establishes my legal status as a citizen
of the State of New Hampshire as defined
by section one of the 14th Amendment of
the US
Constitution professionally I I I've
been a professional dog police dog
trainer and the former can9 manager for
the United States Department of energy I
had 10 bomb dogs under my command and it
was that background that first I first
uh cut my teeth on learning law I didn't
go to law school but because of the
training agencies I had to learn all
their rules their regulations local
ordinances and statutes whether it be
local County state or federal agencies
so that's where my um the beginning of
my interest began from the from a from a
um I've always had an interest in
American history as a hobby I've spent
the last 10 years of my constitutional
studies focused on the New Hampshire
State history of our state constitution
and the form of government created by it
I've read all of the New Hampshire
election laws going back to
1775 and most importantly how the state
and federal Constitution and the
statutes written pursuant thereof work
together on the issues of voting and
immigration both relevant to our
election laws several years ago I was in
Bill Garden office and former Secretary
of State paid me a very very high
compliment in a meeting in his office
with several members of the legislature
when he told the representatives in
attendance that he believed that I knew
more about our Constitution and our
election laws than the lawyers and
judges in the state and I was profoundly
taken back by that and it led to his
invitation to teach a constitutional Law
class to his entire legal staff uh cour
including Bud Fitch um uh many members
of the House of rep representatives were
in attendance I filmed the whole thing
I'd be glad to do it again if anyone is
has the interest but what I did is I
walked everyone through knowing the
beginning real what a real important
part of understanding how to fix
legislation that is being looked at for
revision is to understand where we came
from this is the tool the courts use
right the state supreme court uses the
same instrument which is judicial
scrutiny is always based on what did the
founding fathers say and do at the time
and recently the US Supreme Court has
reaffirmed that and we'll talk about
that later on as to how those recent
precedents are now going to change the
legislation I've argued two cases before
the New Hampshire Supreme Court the
first case being the right to petition
or remonstrate before the legislature
for redress grievances which I alluded
to earlier and the second case of course
was is been remanded back to the trial
court after establishing standing before
the state supreme court I've listed the
video link from the State website if you
care to see it it's those are the links
that would take you there from
2023 proposed election legislation now
before the election law committee I'm
here to share with you the importance of
the historical and legal definitions of
both voting rights and Naturalization
laws of the State of New Hampshire the
following is the foundation or standard
of review that I will use to render my
opinions about any election or
naturalization questions you may pose to
me any of my opinions prop of the
proposed legislation will be mindful of
an important fact that all legislation
must be written
pursuant uh excuse me I lost my way my
opinions will be based uh on proposed
fixes to legislation must be written and
they must survive judicial scrutiny
anyone who's been involved in litigation
um I know sometimes when I hear the
attorneys come testify about proposed
legislation they'll always give that
that cautionary note that in the end
you're likely to have some type of legal
challenge so it's important to go ahead
and make sure that you're mindful of
these things and that's what I want to
cover with you today what are those
constitutional or statutory issues that
are going to hinder a possibly good idea
that has conflicting statutes and that's
where I thought I'd be of great help to
the committee here today so um the the
big part of this too is that uh and
we're going to get into this is Article
90 and that is that retrospect uh
Article 90 which is that all proposed
changes to our statutes must be done so
in harmony with our state and federal
Constitution uh whether the election
laws in the past or the immigration laws
were changed by mistake or design should
not affect this committee's ability to
recommend solutions to the legislature
which is still constitutionally
authorized to fix these issues part one
article 29 leaves to the legisl the
responsibility to suspend the laws or to
make the laws and no other and so that's
really important so you are statute
constitutionally authorized to make
these
fixes the next
part
uh because whatever the legisl whatever
the legislative solution is it must
still be in harmony with part two
Article 90 of the Constitution of New
Hampshire which requires that the common
law which was in effect prior to the
adaptation of any new new proposed
legislation must be in harmony the
backstory to Article 90 is that when New
Hampshire was settled after the
Mayflower Compact and the first settlers
landed here we had nearly 150 years of
occupancy till the Revolution and so
when they wrote the new Constitution
that we're working with today they had
to figure out G which of the Old Law of
the Old English common law that's
practiced here in America what are we
going to keep and what are we going to
push away and of course all the things
that they didn't like that came from the
King they were going to dismiss it so
Article 90 says very clearly all laws
which have heret for been adopted used
and approved in the province Colony or
state of New Hampshire and usually
practice on in the courts of law this is
the key shall remain and be in full
force so when you're dealing with this
in my opinion when you're dealing with a
statute that has um that is is going to
radically change the past you need to
make sure that it isn't going to cause
conflict with the other con consisting
or the other provisions of the
Constitution and or relevant statutes
and then it goes on to say that again
the legislature can in fact make those
changes until altered or repealed by the
legislature and then the caveat such
Parts thereof only accepted as our
repugnant to the rights and Liberties
contained in this constitution so new
new legislation that fixes or attempts
to fix the past must still be in harmony
with the Constitution and this is where
a lot of these things I've discovered
about the
1979 recodification of our election laws
as I said is there are some mistakes
there whether you know doesn't matter
why they're there they're simply there
and uh a lot a lot a lot of this has to
do with the fact that our Civics
curriculum is quite lacking in the state
now we're no longer teaching State the
state constitution in our Civics
curriculum there's no longer that
mandate only that they students only
have to take a federal naturalization
examination as part of their passing
their school curriculum and I think that
that affects uh the lawmaking process
sometimes in a negative way because when
as some people have publicly stated some
some reps have publicly stated that it's
not my job to know whether the proposed
legislation is constitutional it's for
the courts to figure out I would
vehemently disagree with that I know
that I believe that I should say I
believe house the current house rules
govern that every Vice chair of every
committee is supposed to know or make
sure that any proposed legislation in
his committee can only move forward if
in fact it's
constitutional yeah yes uh thank you Mr
Rich want to confirm that that is
actually uh correct that um that is a
rule that we have and um you're
absolutely correct every Vice chairman
of every uh standing committee is um
supposed to do that as part of their
rules so uh thank you I also gave you a
chance to get a drink of water there no
thank you thank you reading the
room um so anyway that's Article 90 now
Article 90 goes on to say that it um
when compared to the 23rd article in the
Bill of Rights shall be cons shall be
construed to affect the laws already
made respecting persons and Estates in
other words you can't pass retrospective
laws that's a big deal so that 90 and 23
work together and by the way most of the
Constitution there's a lot of synergy
and Harmony in the document part one was
was created on purpose the Bill of
Rights is first for a reason there is 38
in the original text more now with
additional amendments and changes but 38
in the original in part two the form of
government in my opinion was written and
in the courts have reaffirmed this was
written specifically to protect part one
that's why it exists so unlike the US
Bill of Rights which is backwards the US
Constitution was written and then the
states half of the states that
considered the adaptation of the US
Constitution wrote what we ultimately
know today is the Bill of Rights New
Hampshire specifically had 12 it had 12
Provisions that said hey if we're going
to to adopt this new document we want to
go ahead and and and and and follow that
course but anyway moving on from there
affidavit
issue let's get to the affidavit issue I
want to begin by uh pointing out um some
misleading testimony a few weeks ago and
I've known secretary scanland for a long
time and I was disappointed um to to to
hear these things but they need to be
addressed and a few weeks ago as you
well know we were here discussing House
Bill through the full committee on house
bill FN 608 or I'm sorry backwards HB
608 FN and that bill is being proposed
to address a conflict with the
interpretation of the word affidavit uh
representative Lane asked a brilliant
question I wanted to LEAP up and hug her
and get her some roses because she asked
the million dooll question right I've
been trying to get the state government
to answer that question what do you
consider a properly executed affidavit
and the sad reality is is that the attor
the Secretary of State withheld some
Vital Information and that Vital
Information is part of this package that
I'll get to it the election procedure
manual is different than law it says on
page four that this is not law and on
on page
154 this is what he left out in his
testimony determining if a voter
properly executed by the way there is an
existing statute that was on the books
when all of this happened last fall
House Bill
1569 that the chair of the of the big
committee passed made a passed the law
that says no exemptions on voter ID the
problem when they did that is that they
actually passed a retrospective law they
repealed
6593 which is the statutory definition
of an affidavit and so it says clearly
there that in the 12 Provisions that the
legislature has established for an
affidavit to be executed it says that
they must all be done under the
traditional Norm right the word is 500
years old the courts have been using it
and still use it you can't have an
admission if you're going to change it
that'd be one thing but they did
upon finding the defect as secretary
scanland gets to in his testimony they
didn't fix or suggest that we fix the
problem they fixed it in the manual and
here it is determining if a voter
properly executed the affidavit envelope
an affidavit is properly executed if a
the voter has completed the affidavit
and signed it with a legible signature
the absentee ballot affidavit envelope
was amended by House Bill 555 and Now
does not require the voter to Mark the
specific circumstances that permits the
use of an absentee ballot the voter
signs the affidavit which states one of
the following applies with me that's a
now before we go any further if we're
going to if the legislature chooses to
reduce and change an affidavit to a uh
an unsworn
declaration right you at least need to
tell the moderator why it is you're
claiming to vote absentee
representative Lane is moving uh a cacr
to kind of go to to eliminate this issue
from a different perspective and but the
way the law reads today uh how can you
even claim that that's in fact uh
permissible right to say well gee and
that's part of my lawsuit which says
look you can't put seven excuses on the
envelope and say and not declare which
of them applies to me never mind there's
no eyewitness and there's no
notarization no chain of custody on this
and this is a big problem B the
affidavit is signed with an illegible
signature you must assume it's the
voter's name think about that
no that that's not a sworn affidavit be
so C again you have to assume that the
person's disabled if you can't read
their signature and and see the one
that's really
bad there's no voter signature on the
affidavit envelope but there is a name
and a signature of the person assisting
the voter you must assume the voter has
a disability it prevents the voter from
signing his or her name in other words
the absentee ballots that are submitted
to your moderators for disabled people
we don't even know who they are because
their name isn't even on the envelope
there's no provision for any there's no
space on that envelope I have a copy
amongst this all of this to to figure
that out it's not even there so this is
a a huge problem uh uh thank you Mr
Richard let me uh let me just uh inter
inter ask a question just a moment just
to confirm um we know exactly where
you're reading from that that is the 20
24 the current version with the pretty
purple cover to it and that's the
election law manual and you're reading
page 154 duties of the
moderators duties of the moderators and
so that
uh and it's
your
um premise or assertion I don't mean to
imply any uh thing in there but that uh
secretary the Secretary of State's
office through the election law manual
attempt attempted
to
um oh wait no that would not have been
uh 1569 would not have been in place no
until correct so
so that is so the election law manual is
not reflective of
1569 well my issue with the election
procedure manual is simple the
legislature makes the law they don't
that's what I left that's what I teed
off for this for the secretary in his
testimony was I said look the
legislature makes the law Secretary of
State can't make law and neither can the
Attorney General's office and the State
of Arizona has just held their Secretary
of State in contempt of court for the
same issue the difference between
Arizona's election procedure manual and
the uh New Hampshire the only difference
there is that they permit by Statute
that Arizona by Arizona law that the
manual is enforced as law because it's
written by the legislature and not
modified by the Secretary of State and
that's where the Arizona Secretary of
State got in got himself in trouble it's
the same thing going on here
is that seeing a defect or a difference
of opinion they've chosen to write a
solution as if it they have lawmaking
power and they don't now if the
legislature wants to do this that's for
the legislature to decide but not for
the Secretary of State because he has no
lawmaking power he's the secretary and
and he reaffirmed this in his testimony
over the printing of the election manual
excuse me the printing of the text on
the envelope on the absentee affid David
envelope he said I'm powerless I don't I
follow the law right that was his
testimony and he's testified the same
and he's correct when he says that he
doesn't have any discretionary authority
to make law neither does the attorney
general and I think there's a serious
defect in in uh separation of powers
over this issue of letting those two do
this because again it's up to the
legislature to do these things and
that's really my my disagreement with it
is not so much the substance of this
but so so uh again just sorry for the
interruption just a quick question is so
is the recent ruling on bruan and its
impact on administrative
rules
um is is that wrong case but that's I
get where you're going with that okay is
I know where you're going the right case
then so the the right case you'd be
talking about would be the more V Harper
decision and also the uh decision last
summer which is the NAACP of South
Carolina versus the South Carolina
legislature and where there is a lot
where I found a lot of case precedent to
support my position in fed over Federal
issues was uh all these redistricting
fights when they end up in front of the
Supreme Court they always say the same
thing we don't have the authority we
can't tell the state government how to
redistrict that's for the state
legislature and or the federal Congress
if you look at the part of Article 1
Section 4 of the US Constitution Clause
2 that if the there's a fascinating
story I'll tell you about on that in a
second but that provision says that if
the state legislature refuses to
establish the time place and manner for
conducting the
elections that the federal Congress can
and and the mor V Harper decision it
went further and it said we as the
Supreme Court are not delegated any
power under article 3 to do this so it
belongs with the state legislature and
again if they're going to fix the
problem because the states refuse and
that's matter of fact you find that in
article four of New Hampshire's uh
consent to the US Constitution the
fourth provision in that document was
that that we will we agree to the new
Constitution under these conditions and
one of them was that the federal
legislature never exercised the state
legislator's powers unless the state
refused to establish the time place in
Manner and I found it fascinating that
New Hampshire put that there as one of
their conditions but that's a big piece
of it all right uh thank you I didn't
mean to take you too far down a side uh
Road there but I appreciate the
testimony about that that's that is of
course of interest to us as well um from
an election law perspective but uh let's
return to um the affidavit issue that
you were disc discussing and if you
would continue with your testimony that
would be uh much appreciated thank you
you're
welcome yeah I was looking back on page
four I went too
far okay there we go also another
decision I I stopped where I was talking
about Article 90 and I wanted to
reaffirm reaffirm that from the state
supreme court in a long time ago in a
famous case that still stands today
Merill versus Sherburn Merill versus
Sherburn reaffirmed the repugnant or
contrary Provisions in the constitution
in three places and it when it said the
following quote that clause which
confers upon the general court the
authority to make laws provides at the
same time that they must not be
repugnant or contrary to the
Constitution and that's exactly what Mor
V Harper did which was another
redistricting case that case had to do
with the North Carolina legislature
spearheaded by a republican majority
abused their power they abused their
power and they said hey
since since we get our power to
redistrict federally from the federal
elections Clause no one can tell us what
to do and that's what took them all the
way to the Supreme Court and the Supreme
Court said sit down little boys and
girls yes we are going to tell you what
to do and so that's where it and all of
those cases by the way that are part of
uh some of these additional filings I
have for you to to read at your leisure
uh all address the same thing they're
all about that the state lawmaking power
must always follow the State
Constitution and it can't delegate its
Authority I'm not going to get into the
ballot law commission but some of this
case deals with that also of delegating
lawmaking power to that body as well
to continue here with this um what I
wanted and I just alluded to this about
his testimony is that he affirms the
secretary affirmed some of my arguments
in part some of it was misleading in
part and some of it was flatly not very
honest and and I wanted to make sure
that this committee understood this and
I I voed these concerns to cheer uh
chair chairman Barry as well um there
are eight relevant issues to this
election law case regarding secretary
scandin public testimony on the
affidavit question a secretary SC excuse
me secretary scandin testimony addressed
the proposed legislative amendment to
fix 659
51b and that's what house bill 608 is
trying to fix is to clarify the
discrepancy between the statutory
definition of a qu of an affidavit the
execution of an affidavit and the
election procedure man manual because
we've been operating under the procedure
manual and not following the
law if if I may just to just to clarify
um uh you may continue your testimony um
but just um I was notified that there
was in fact an error in the public
announcement of the working session
regarding um the possibility of working
on HB 608 that was already exec um by
the full committee and therefore that
will not be um handled any further by
the subcommittee but if you're having
testimony relevant to the theme as a
whole and it in involves your
considerations of 608 I think we can
still hear that without any problem just
the committee will not be working on
that so just just um that was announced
at the beginning um but not everyone was
here at that time so I just want to uh
make that announcement again and clarify
so um thank you yeah no I bring that
issue up only because the secretary and
the AG's defense on this issue has been
to look at to ignore the moderator's
duty and focus exclusively on the voters
responsibility how to how to properly
vote the voting process and the
beginning of the chain of custody so
he's complete he's now telling us that
he's aware of the issue because in the
court what he's doing is he's there one
I'm sure that the AG isn't thrilled for
him to have testified and now now we
have now they're actually saying
something about an issue that if their
Council had the had better oversight
they would have said don't say anything
but they did so now there's a conflict
between him and the Secretary of State
on this issue and that is that uh you
know again they're using the election
procedure manual they're not following
the state
law B on the second part of his
testimony was just what I alluded to
6577 does not contain the language
directing the SOS to print the notary
certificate on the return envelope and
that's what his testimony then and what
I brought with me today are the the the
historical Journey from
1942 up till current and we'll cover
that when we get there
uh just to uh U not to spoil your
punchline but um Ju Just In in two
summaries H uh had it been there before
and and it has been since removed is
that what exactly that's exactly right
so the process was in effect from 1942
and I have a copy of that Amendment from
1942 to
1979 and uh that's exactly right it was
there before and they they kept the word
the same so the envelope that had a
notary certificate and that process was
in place was called an affidavit
envelope and the name stayed the same
even though the duties of both the
moderator and or excuse me the
moderator's duty stayed the same but the
voter's Duty
changed so the voter is no longer
statutorily bound to appear before
anyone and and so that's been their
legal defense is that well I only print
the envelope the way it's instructed to
and that says that under the current
statutory scheme that the voter doesn't
have to do these things and that's going
to be part of this committee's decision
affidavits the next piece on this um he
secretary scandin also reaffirmed my
testimony on the all this historical
thing he broke it down very well and I
have a copy part of my testimony that
I've got here is the transcript of that
I did my own transcript as best I could
um he also reaffirmed that uh the state
election laws were in fact recodified in
1979 and uh the afores said changes
included most of the election statutes
now in question here
today uh e that he the SOS has
directions on the language that shall
appear on the envelope this is true it's
exactly correct he he follows the
statute as it's written now there's a
conflict of interest between the
Secretary of State and the AGS office uh
I'm sorry yeah Secretary of State in the
AG's office because now he's giving
rather than remaining silent they're now
giving testimony on this issue and so
that's not going to work out so well for
them but anyway um and then of course uh
representative Lane asked the brilliant
question what do you consider then to be
a proper affidavit and he told us uh
from his perspective uh secretary
scandal's testimony is also relevant
because of the conflicting testimony
between the two and so next in line um
if you follow through on bottom of page
six is actually his testimony I would
like to run through it briefly if that's
okay if I could ask you just to maybe
touch upon some highlights I I think
again I would reiterate that um some of
your comments early on that this was an
inherited an inherited uh aspect that uh
the secretary has had to deal with and
so it's all in print here so I'll skip
over and get to the money the money on
end responding to representative Lane's
question he said the following well I
think the
case in this case the affidavit is what
the legislature calls
it but sure there is a legal definition
of what an affidavit constitutes and I
think Mr Richard is well schooled in
that but I think the legislature can say
something and mean something else
this is a big big problem are you
telling me that if the legislature
writes a statute that you don't
necessarily agree with it that you have
somehow a discretionary authority to use
the election procedure manual to fix the
problem that's what's happened here and
that's where we're going to need a
fix I I will make a charitable note uh
is that sometimes the
legislature um May May in fact write
contradictory laws themselves because we
are gifted in our ability to do that um
present company accepted of course and
so um I I will um I will give the
benefit of Doubt to all parties involved
as much as I can um but
um uh so thank you for the clarification
I appreciate that please please continue
um I know you
have
um 17 pages of testimony so I don't I
don't want you to miss any you put it
all down I did I I did ask that in my
email and at at at the bequest of my
bipartisan requesters of your presence
here so I I acknowledge my failings in
in saying something like keep it to
eight pages but having um since you have
been done so well to put this all I
guarantee you we are all readers here on
this subcommittee this will not go
unread awesome I want you to know that
so um
but uh may I may I suggest that uh you
continue to go through
here uh do you think you could be
finished I can speak three or 3:15 I
think I can be done by 3:15
okay yes oh please anytime yes um thank
you and um
so can the legislature
decide what an affidavit is if it chose
to do so I believe it could because it
is the ultimate law all that power is
delegated to that body for that purpose
and so I think that's what secretary
scanland was saying is that that the
legislature defines the word and what
you find throughout if we use all of the
other places in state in where
affidavits are required and I did this
study there's 262 places in state law
where in specific places where there is
a specific process required because of
the purpose of the affidavit you'll find
that the either the federal Congress or
the state legislature will Define the
parameters for that application and in
this case if they was going to do so
that would be a fix the only caveat
being as long as it's not contrary or
provision so it it doesn't necessarily
have to be consistent does it with the
other chapters of the law this is my
question to you or can we Define it for
purposes of the election law um like the
650s all those it did 65 930 before it
was repealed right and it was there
before uh before the recodification
and and let me make a really important
distinction about affidavits and and a
lot of people that I heard testimony to
when I testified last time were
concerned about the burden it may place
on the voter and they were skipping the
all important point that I'm going to
touch upon now with the Supreme Court
case in in my Supreme Court case and
that is it's not just about the
affidavit it's about the chain of
custody and the beginning of the chain
of custody in other words if we're going
to apply election laws equally to
everybody then the practice that was in
place for in-person voting should apply
equally to C he voting and that's what
they did in 1942 that's what was in
effect in s till
1979 and these changes either by
designer mistake came to be and this is
why we have this dis disparity and so
the key is that that was removed in 79
was the following a voter upon receiving
his absentee ballot package has a
responsibility under the old Provisions
to show up in front of an election law
official that would be one of five p
people a notary a Justice of the Peace A
selectman a clerk or a moderator all
five of them under the 6593 were
authorized to act in that capacity and
what was required was one they would
verify that the mar ballot wasn't
pre-marked the the super whoever is
helping you vote absentee confirms your
ballot isn't pre-marked then the next
thing they would do is uh uh you'd mark
it in the vicinity just like we do in
person and then you'd go into deposit
your ballot into an envelope instead of
a box or a machine and there was an
eyewitness just like it is in person so
the the notary certificate was just the
sealing the deal right confirming that
the process we now have a lawful chain
of custody and everyone's being treated
the same so that was the that that's the
real underlying issue it's not just
about having it notorized it's about
starting a lawful chain of custody and
of course now
659 adds an additional complication how
are we going to now not address this
issue because now we're going to run
into the equal protection clause and let
me share with you the state Supreme
Court's decision in my case I only
Cherry Picked the point the relevant
relevant
point I line
20 quoting this the court the plaintiff
alleges in his complaint that the
defendants sanctioning of discretionary
use of voting machines at the local
level violates the equal protection
Clause of part one article one of the
State Constitution and the 14th
Amendment to the US Constitution by
authorizing uh use of programmable open-
Source electronic voting machines in
town in some towns and cities or other
political subdivisions of the state or
not this is a big problem right when the
statutes were passed in
1979 they were done for a trial basis
for a temporary trial basis and I think
this is what was going on then that that
they didn't realize they were in erting
a secondary problem which is this
problem now so in order to treat
everyone the same are we going to force
the 103 towns in the state an unfunded
mandate to say Hey you now have to get
machines like everybody else or are we
going to force the 135 towns to say you
can't use machines until the legislature
figures this problem out that's what
they did in Massachusetts by the way
because these Provisions John Adams
wrote the Massachusetts Constitution we
used it as a temp
and so that voting provision was the
same and so Massachusetts to address the
voting machine issue did in fact put it
on a cacr and they got it approved and
so it's uniformed throughout the state
of Massachusetts whether you like it
dislike it or not that's now a provision
in their in their constitution and it's
not here this is one of the other
underlying issues is that we have all
103 towns that choose not to we have 135
to do now this really gets compounded in
a bad bad way when we go to the next
step with the affidavit problem I argued
on appeal uh very
importantly that if the moderator does
not authenticate that the affidavit was
properly executed under that provision
65950 B which is the affidavit appears
to be properly executed and he goes
ahead and removes it out of the envelope
instead of disposing it as required by
state statute
65953 material defective that's the
requirement on that as far as dealing
with an envelope that is not properly
executed and so if you go down that
I uh so you uh you were talking about
the affid Davids in the context of the
absentee ballots correct and so um and
and pointing out the there's a section
of the rsa's uh beginning at
65946 and continuing on for several
Pages uh up through 659
55 that concern the processing of
absentee ballots and so I think I was at
the Supreme Court I found my way okay
great thank you I I stalled as long as I
could that's okay so the four the four
items the disparity in the towns using
machines versus not and then the
counting of unverified ballots they
found problematic and the second issue
is that as soon as you remove an a
ballot from an absentee envelope that
doesn't have a properly executed
affidavit you put it in a machine it
can't be
reconciled Hava required that all the
states adopt a proper manner in which we
can do proper recounts and there's
another reason that that ballot can't be
recounted it's not a lawful affidavit
it's not admissible in a court of
law so we have a secondary problem so
you you're puzzled but go ahead ask
so um could could you uh repeat your
statement regarding how this violates
Hava yes if there's no way to do a
lawful recount because even though
absentee ballots are are in some cases
of a different color they're named on
the face as an absentee ballot the
problem is is that if they've been
removed from the affidavit instrument
and put in the
machine now there's no way to reconcile
who is who because we don't know if
let's say you have a th000 absentee
ballots and you don't know which one
some people by the way who do return
their absentee ballots let's say you're
you're scheduled on a trip you apply for
an absentee ballot and then you find out
that your trip is canceled some people
will simply take that absentee ballot go
to the town they'll happy to check you
in right so some of those will actually
have a notary authentification it goes
back to the to to the town at the local
level for counting um
so 103 to 135 is one unverified ballots
is two three is the inability to recount
them properly and four certifying the
election with unverified
ballots may I ask you a a practical
question about this aspect of recounts
and the absentee ballots
maintain you're worried about the chain
of custody when there is not an
official a not not a legal
affidavit so if if someone had a legal
affidavit and removed it
from the from the envelope from the
envelope and then processed
it would that be acceptable under those
conditions or not well it would be the
problem is you have all the others that
aren't that's where you get into trouble
right is that it's not the person who
actually has a lawful ex lawfully
executed affidavit it's deluding that
vote when you then then add all of the
others that have not been checked and by
the way in 2020 just so you know we
maintained an average of 4% of the three
previous election Cycles prior to 2020
4% is our average okay 2020 with the
expanded absentee Provisions that were
brought about because of covid and other
expansions but statutorily uh we went to
32% over 260,000 absentee back Bots and
one of the things uh one of the things
the Supreme Court found and I I'll
finish up their quote according to the
plain if this disparity between methods
of counting votes and the non
verifiability of ballots submitted by
electronic voting machine at the time of
counting and later for auditing
parentheses recounts the validity of
each ballot and vote produce an
unreliable outcome and a hidden
opportunity to manipulate the computer
counted data see I didn't argue that the
machine were being flipped that they
were being accessed electronically I
simply argued there's a process and the
process isn't being followed because
that is the only statutory enforcement I
have under under election Purity 666 col
2 and 666 col three are the statutory
Provisions where if local election
officials or anyone in in involved with
the election process doesn't follow the
process that is my only statutory relief
available to me so claiming fraud and
and my argument in my brief was every
single absentee ballot is they're all
defective and when you say defective
just just to make sure I understand um
is because it did not have a proper uh a
legal affidavit that that established as
you discussed the lawful chain of
custody
if is that that's correct right you're
right all right and then just to follow
up on that so if let me take one extreme
and say if every absentee ballot had
come in with a
legal affidavit as we've defined at
least in our discussions here at that
point that would have been acceptable
because there was at that point a lawful
chain of custody would have been
established I'm trying to think about
legislative Solutions it's not just your
your case specifically and that's the
point of my question so if it had had
the full legal affidavit at least that
aspect of your case would have not been
gerine because every every absentee
ballot at that point would have had a
legal chain of custody right and that's
what the affidavit is it's verification
of the beginning of the chain of custody
that's the key here so it's not just the
affidavit instrument by itself self but
rather that someone witnessed you insert
your ballot inside of an envelope and
that begins the process it is the it is
the um not again not to put words in
your mouth but I
think we because of the equal um
treatment of people's equal protection
Clause we cannot
treat someone who has an absentee ballot
different from someone who is in who is
present on Election Day
and in the election day mechanism where
people are present they have people who
are witnessing them handing out ballots
putting them and following and tracking
them from taking that ballot
from the point where uh they're
obtaining a
ballot uh confirming their registration
obtaining a ballot marking it as
necessary and then delivering it to the
machine that chain of custody is
established by the
witnesses at that election poll correct
and the only difference the only
difference between the absentee voter in
the affidavit is the extra step but the
extra step is necessary to not be
burdened with voting with everyone else
on Election Day right if you're going to
be exempt from that process because I
did hear that in testimony from opposing
opposing the bill explaining the burden
that that that may befall certain people
because of their health conditions or
others and so they brought that up as a
great question so yes I think that's the
answer so uh representative C first and
then um representative Lane all right
thank you um I'm I'm gathering that uh
it's it's a two-part question here I'm
gathering that uh for the affidavit on
absente ballot it only needs to start
the chain of command or the chain of
custody at the time the person is going
to Mark the ballot and put it in the
envelope correct so wouldn't need it
just to you know call up the clerk's
office and say hey send me a absentee
ballot or anything like that well I
don't see anything broken with the
current application process in other
words everyone the the key in article 11
of the Bill of Rights establishes that
you're already a qualified voter which
means you're already registered in your
local community so when you apply for
your absentee ballot if you're not
already registered they can't send out a
package they have to make sure that you
are in fact registered in your local
community so that's an important
distinction and then then to follow on
on that uh the various people who can be
the legal Witnesses notaries justice of
peace and whatever uh what happens if
you're out of the state or out of the
country do we need to
have uh well out of state you can get a
notary or Justice P easily enough do we
need to have them certify where they
have their
commission well uh I my answer is always
what was going on before the beauty of
our state is that we have been here so
long in a continuous manner that my
first my first problem solving tool is
to go back and what were they doing
before we changed it and was that a bad
move and so that would be that would be
my response to address that issue okay
and then the only other part of that is
if you're out of the country would uh
would a u i know the military has has
deferred to their commanding officers as
a surrogate and so that's always been
the I believe the way we deal with UK
possibly Embassy Personnel or something
like that correct correct thank I think
there are other uh states that have that
in their election laws that you can use
an embassy or conselor something that
extent so um representative
Lane
um my concern and I've heard what you
were saying but my concern goes back to
you know if we look at what was
happening in
1979 what if we're not happy with what
they were doing because there are a lot
of people who can't you know they're
homebound or right there how do we again
to Echo the the legislative mind so how
do we resolve that issue but yet try to
treat them the same great question and I
think the answer is in Article 90 and
that's why I started early on in
explaining that is whatever changes the
legislature proposes and it's free to do
so right it's it's it's Unlimited in its
capacity to offer Solutions it is not
constrained by anything other than both
constitutions so if like for example
with the cacr that you proposed right
I'm not for or against the bill all I'm
pointing out in my that I think I
pointed out in my testimony was that
that provision runs into other problems
that that other provisions of the
constit they would have to be altered as
well and I think that's the so if we're
going to be a a recodification for
example right that things need to change
for whatever reason that we're still
Bound by making those changes because AR
one of the Bill of Rights says all
government of right originates from the
people and the last sentence of article
101 in part two says that this document
can't be changed without the consent of
the people right and so this is this is
uh an important piece so that would be
my answer uh to and I say this to people
all the time if if you sometimes the U
proposed legislative changes are um I'll
pick on Parental Bill of Rights for a
moment since I know it's a Hot Topic my
my my argument is it's not necessary
it's not necessary because the parents
already possess that Authority Under The
Bill of Rights so the fact that you've
surrendered your children to the state
is another problem that's the real
problem so don't complain how they
handle it
example uh uh representative Burnham yes
thank you um do you think that absentee
ballots should be held accountable just
like official ballots uh and I mean
accountable from the moment that a clerk
receives them from the Secretary of
State's office official official ballots
are are counted right by wi uh and
witness of those countings they are
separated by um testing
samples
um or from samp from the testing samples
and then they are placed in sealed until
election day okay so that process has
happened with the official ballots
however when they receive absente
ballots from the Secretary of State's
office it is not handled that way you're
right and uh when you look back at the
past you'll see that the um uh the
absentee voting process is uh been
monkeyed with for a long time and I
don't uh please re rephrase the question
for
me do you believe that the absentee
ballots should receive the same chain of
custody and accountability as our
official ballots article 11 says so
right that the election process must be
fair and equal throughout so this is
what's not happening now is that we're
not we're not treating them the same
they're being treated differently
because there's no verification of who
they are like I said earlier we've gone
from and the word affidavit to a process
that closely resembles an unsworn
declaration so it that's not what it is
I mean if if the legislature was going
to make it that then it run into other
problems of not being able to verify so
the answer to your question is yes I
believe that they should be and they
have to be dealt with the same way they
can't be treated differently I have a
followup please um so with that in mind
currently absente ballots aren't counted
they're not being tracked um some clerks
say that they do track a personally just
so that they are aware who they sent uh
how many times they may have sent one
out to a voter because sometimes that
happens they may not receive it on the
other end or they may have thrown it
away or maybe they went somewhere else
and they needed in a new location none
of those are necessarily being tracked
from my understanding um and then
they're not being
counted reduced from the total of
whatever total that is from the
Secretary of State's office they're not
being counted at the clerk's office the
only absentee ballots that are being
counted are the absentee ballots that
are being used as an official ballot if
they've run out of the official
ballots or any absentee ballots received
to be processed on Election Day there is
nothing in between if they've been
spoiled like our official ballots right
our official ballots are spoiled those
are C calculated as well in the final
count of their ballots and at the end of
the day we don't know how many absentee
ballots we have remaining but we do for
the official ballots the process is not
the same and I'm just my understanding
is that there's no need to have to worry
about that it's the absentee ballots
that are being processed through the
machine or hand counted and that's
really part of the problem is that
you'll find this fascinating when they
first made these provisions and
recodification
1979 if you were using voting machines
in your local voting district you
couldn't count the absentee ballots you
had to count them by hand and you
couldn't start counting them till the
election was done so at the end of the
day was when they were done so they were
all put aside and once the election day
was over then the moderator would make
his announcement that he's going to
start counting them but yeah they used
to not because remember part two article
32 of the uh the the election U
provision for the moderator selectman
and clerk says the moderator is to sort
and count the machine can't sort they
can't do an examination of the ballot
and that also when we when we added this
piece to it to the election process we
also the eliminated the problem of doing
the fix before the certification so the
moderator could fix this problem in the
moment and and so some of these changes
like I don't agree with the the starting
early in the day only because if people
want to challenge most people are
working 9 to5
uh or whatever their time frame is if
you start doing it early in the day
you're unable to make these challenges
and and now we're being legally
threatened with consequences but that's
another
story I do have one more but I let me
just just to clarify your your questions
and and the response so there's a
distinction between an absente ballot
package and then uh which contains a set
of envelopes right two envelopes two
envelopes an affidavit envelope and a
mailing envelope and then there's also
the the blank ballot and then we've been
talking about you've been talking about
before the ballot is marked my earlier
conversation with Mr Richard discussed
the ballot after it was marked and the
chain of custody so I just want to
clarify we're using the same terms but
we need to make sure we distinguish
where in the life cycle uh that ballot
is so um I just wanted to clarify that
for anyone who might be listening or
thinking about this um so um did you say
you had another question ah so um we
will entertain uh representative
Lan's uh she's had enough we'll uh we'll
get we'll get back to representative
Burnham in a second but I have to give
you I have to give equal treatment here
as as the chair I'm trying to do a
balanced uh uh unbiased situation so
representative Lane please ask your
question
so with my legisl lative hat on and
trying to craft an
affidavit and you talked about
self-affirming so I'm kind of going
that's not really in your mind an
affidavit no no based on usage and
custom and history the word is 500 years
old right and and the courts have
established its definition and so is the
legislature in 262 places okay if we
wanted to yes if we wanted to say a
self-affirming
affidavit would suffice because they're
signing to say it's subject to the
penalties of
perjury that we lay out what the
penalties are that there's a civil
penalty and a criminal penalty and all
that and they sign that in your mind
it's not an and I agree it's not an
affidavit correct but would that be
enforcable in court if they've signed it
uh no because there was no witness right
we we there's no beginning of the chain
of custody because that's all the
affidavit is for is to reaffirm that
we've begun with the in other words
everyone who cast a ballot must cast The
Ballot in front of someone authorized by
law to be an election official and
so have you thought about how we might
try and solve this cuss chain of custody
issue for people who really are
homebound or can't get into the clerk's
office um and don't necessarily have the
money to pay I mean it can cost anywhere
from 50 to $100 to get someone to come
to your home right and sign an affidavit
yeah no my answer to that would be to do
what we used to do in the past for
example people in nursing homes right
dispatch someone who was authorized to
do so at the state or local people in
other words at local expense to make
sure that they get to right to exercise
their right to vote and and I that would
be the solution is to make it be part of
the responsibility because the state
carries the burden to make sure that um
uh that the uh the voter Integrity is is
maintained so then it would be incumbent
upon the clerks or the whoever we decide
to go out to these people not I mean
they're not all in nursing homes a lot
of them are you know living in
apartments or living in their homes so
do we then have it be the responsibility
of the clerks to go out say on
designated dat I I don't even know I'm
kind of yeah yeah no and be honest with
you it's beyond my pay grade to make
that decision because I'm not in the
legislature so I can't speculate to I'll
to no you're welcome so uh I'll move
along here get on to I think my Mr
Richard um I'm now uh now that we've uh
allowed representative Lane a turn we're
we're now back to representative Burnham
to uh follow up with her questions thank
you I'm just really passionate about my
absente ballot there you go I'm glad you
are so kind of been on this for a little
while and I'm just want some clarity uh
and support would be great um so with
that I we find that there are some
people that cannot come into a polling
place but they can be driven to say the
door and the moderator can come outside
or ballot election official with an
absentee ballot so that now that
absentee ballot which has had not been
counted right comes outside and it's
being witnessed by that elected official
of the voter completing that ballot but
it's still an absentee ballot my I've
never gotten the a firm answer as to why
that needs to be an absentee ballot
versus an official day ballot when the
voters coming to the location but not
inside right because now you have what I
can tell you from a practical
perspective is the absentee ballot is
labeled as such all absentee ballots are
printed absentee ballot at the header
and many of them are a different color
so um so you'd be looking at a
legislative solution to convert an
absentee ballot into a normal ballot now
there used to be and there may still be
I don't know the solid I'm not solid on
this answer but there used to be the
ability to uh take that absentee ballot
and do exactly that to show up on
Election Day and have it deposited
either at the polling station or by any
other means with the only caveat of
getting it processed before the polls
close so it's a risky game of being way
too late on that but yeah I I I don't
see a problem with that and it is part
of our usage and custom of the
past you're
welcome I I'll just say this as a sort
of rhetorical question it might have to
do with processing of ballots within the
guard rails and things like that so I
I'm yeah I'm thinking that's why when
you're taking a ballot outside of the
guard rails within that election polling
place you are you you should not be
taking regular ballots so you take an
absentee balot I think that's the
rationale of I'm not sure that the I'm
not sure that the RSA specifies that it
might specify that in the election law
manual again something for the election
law committee to consider yeah I
appreciate that I I think the level of
concern is the voters they don't they've
taken the time to come out even as far
as they can uh be whatever their
situation and when they see that it's an
absentee ballot they feel like they've
been dismissed in such a way that it's
not the official one that's all I'm
asking if how how does that play for
their own particular situation so I I I
think that's that's something that we
should consider in the larger committee
about how to properly address that
aspect so that there are
some um everyone here knows that I'm
very passionate about uh the ability of
people who have uh disabilities and
other similar challenges must their
their right to vote must be protected
and um I think we just need to clarify
how that uh is enacted in a way that
they don't feel uh discriminated against
or in some manner so uh
excellent line of questioning thank you
very much uh representative Newsome
thank you very much and I'd like to
apologize to the subcommittee and uh our
guest for my tardiness uh this
afternoon that's fine I still want to
get that on record so um and I'm not
sure if this really matters in the grand
scheme but in your opinion when does an
absentee voter technically vote is it
when the ballot goes in the envelope and
is
sealed or puts in in the
mailbox or when it's received on the
other end and I'm not really sure if it
matters in the grant scheme I'm just
curious what your thoughts on that might
be yeah no I would say that it the
ballot has been cast once it's been
received by the moderator and then the
moderator has a three-step process a to
make sure that the voter is is a um on
the checklist that's the first step B
that the affidavit appears to be
properly executed and C that the
signature verification is also
uh is also in line now there's I don't
want to get off in the weeds but we
could have this conversation offline
about saato versus Garder where this
went to the federal court and there was
some hanky panky that went on and we'll
take that offline but yeah it's it's
it's been an
issue but that would be my answer to
your question so yeah the fact the fact
that well and again what I like about
the affidavit process is that now it's
been sealed and there's an eyewitness so
that when you go to check C and this is
what they didn't tell the federal court
is that you have an authenticated
signature to verify if you don't have a
notary or an eyewitness to the inserting
the ballot in the envelope how can you
trust the signature the state brought in
the S the ACLU brought in a signature
verification expert Who convinced the
federal judge that moderators lack the
skill set the training or professional
capacity to discern to a certain degree
to disallow a ballot based on the fact
that the signature didn't match
moderators don't have that skill and I
wouldn't disagree with that opinion but
they left out the important part that if
they did the affidavit then the
moderator would be looking at an
authenticated signature and we're no
long we we don't have that that hasn't
happened since 79 right so the
authenticated signature being the not
not the public notary not the actual
voter in this case right the notary
verified that that was a signature right
so the moderator could trust it because
he he personally had an eyewitness right
and and part of the notary process would
have been to confirm identity and
confirm that all the other attributes
for voting were being followed as I.E
different than what representative Lane
was talking about which is an unsworn
declaration that's the legal term and in
some jurisdiction it is permissible and
I would say that it would have to be
done by the legislature in order for
that to be done but not the ball law
commission I'm sorry frean slip um not
by the uh the secretary of state of the
AG um next I have for you hopefully the
solution your do so uh because there
have been a number of questions you're
certainly extended Beyond 3:15 um the
meeting is supposed to last till 4 so I
I um uh please continue uh but but uh
don't feel pressure to end by 3:15 I I
want to you know extend as much courtesy
as I to you as I possibly can because
this has been I think very informative
and I think the subcommittee greatly
appreciates your testimony here today so
if you would uh continue but I will
advise you you're on page nine of 17 and
it is 306 so I I ask you to your best
and I know I know uh from your dog
training skills that you'll be able to
do this sool confident in you all right
for you non-lawyers here um I'm going to
close out on my point about my the state
supreme court the court said the
following applying our standard of
review based on the alleged facts we
determined that the plaintiff is
sufficiently demonstrated his right to
claim relief and he's therefore
demonstrated standing in his equal
protection claim and they cited several
cases noting in this applies to everyone
to should all know this noting that
voters have standing to bring equal
protection challenges to complain on
vote delusion and observing that quote
many of the cases have assumed rather
than articulated the premise of deciding
the me merits of similar claims in other
words proving fraud is very difficult
the fact that I went down this road is
why I was able to convince the state
supreme court that this should move
forward um because the trial court did
not address the plaintiff's equal
protection claim we remand for further
proceedings consistent with this
decision in doing so we express no
opinion on the merits of the claim
that's because the TR the state supreme
court is an appell at court and so it
didn't want to taint beyond the finding
of standing and again for the non-
lawyers standing Doctrine is layman's
term a good example is that there's an
injury in fact that I suffered some type
of legal or concrete injury number two
the causation that the alleged injury is
fairly traceable and challenge to the
challenge conduct and lastly
redressability the court can redress the
alleged injury if grants the plaintiff
the requested relief and that's a close
out on the um on this on my case um one
of my favorite subjects State
citizenship not knowing the difference
between state and federal jurisdiction
has caused us all kinds of trouble and
I'm hoping to make it really simple for
you here today so that's the header of
my third cat third and final category
today question number three question of
citizenship citizen of the State of New
Hampshire versus a citizen of the United
States what's the difference and how
does it affect voting rights and
immigration Naturalization rights most
people don't put the two together but
they're directly connected and you'll
see why when I get there I'm going to
quote an old case it's uh one of my
favorites Susan B Anthony was famous for
women's suffrage but she's also famous
for another issue which is her case in
1873 which I'm going to quote the US
Supreme Court on the right of privilege
of voting is one arising under the
constitution of the state and not under
the Constitution of the United States
the qualifications are different in
different states citizenship age sex
residence are virt are variously
required in the different states or may
be so if the right belongs to any
particular person it's because such a
person is entitled to it by the laws of
the state where he offers to exercise it
and not because of citizenship of the
United States States US versus
Anthony the excuse me the confusion for
most people begins with the wrong
understanding of the US Constitution
14th Amendment which states quote all
persons born or naturalized in the
United States and subject to the
jurisdiction thereof are citizens of the
United States and the state wherein they
reside article 4 section two of the US
Constitution provides citizens of each
state shall be entitled to privilege and
immunities of citizens of the several
States citing or citing US versus
Anthony this right to travel and its
protections afforded to citizens of the
several states does not include the
right of suffrage under the state or US
Constitution so let me break this all
down for you what they're basically
saying is that the 14th amendment was a
solution uh to the the free slave
problem right so what did they do the
the black codes and the black rules were
excluding freed African slaves from
their their right of suffrage and to be
treated like other state citizens and so
what happened for many years I believed
wrongly that the US Constitution or the
14th amendment created two class of
citizenship one state One Federal until
I figured out that no it didn't do that
at all 14th amendment made very clear
that if you are a citizen of a state
you're also a citizen of the United
States and then the rest of the 14th
Amendment would apply to you right the
equal protection the due process clause
those Provisions would apply to you as a
citizen of a state and whenever from
that point on it's my opinion from that
point on whenever you see the word
citizen of the United States you're
looking at Federal jurisdiction key
because I pointed out article 4 section
two the privileges and immunities clause
and by the way your right to travel
under that provision deals with Commerce
and it's articulated very eloquently in
the article four of the um Articles of
Confederation and the Supreme Court has
reaffirmed if you really want to know
what the privileges and immunities
clause says read that because that's
what the Supreme Court says it should be
what its interpretation and what does
that mean you have the protected right
under the US Constitution to travel
anywhere you want you can go from New
Hampshire to California to Alaska to
Hawaii unfettered no checking at the
border um and
the right to be treated for example
you're born in Massachusetts you're a
Massachusetts citizens citizen by birth
but you want to run a business in New
Hampshire across the border New
Hampshire has to treat you the same as
its own citizens it can't treat you
differently but guess what there isn't
there is no case precedent there is no
uh Provisions whatsoever where the 14th
Amendment
nullifies the the uh privileges and
immunities clause in other words the
privileg an immunities clause when you
move from California let's say you were
born there and you move and you want to
go to school at UNH or Dartmouth or
wherever right you don't automatically
inherit the right to vote when you
arrive here and I'm going to use my
personal uh my personal story as an
example I was born in Canada was
naturalized in New Hampshire when I
joined the military they shipped me to
Texas I was still a citizen of New
Hampshire and when I lived in Texas I
was a Texas resident see the words have
been manipulated in flipped around
causing a lot of confusion but I was a
resident of Texas residing there because
of military duty and I had to vote
absentee in New Hampshire just like the
college kids should in my opinion and
then when I was deployed to the deployed
to Europe was a living in the United
Kingdom for three years I was a resident
of the United Kingdom but I was still a
citizen of New Hampshire and for federal
purposes a citizen of the United States
so this is the key to this change and I
found the evidence in the original 1808
law of New Hampshire where there is the
provision to make this all
happen now currently this is really
important part the word inhabitant is
defined by the Constitution in part two
article 30 and it means specifically
someone that possesses political Rights
Article 30 when it was first written in
1784 before it was altered in
1976 said that all persons born or
naturalized I'm sorry I'm quoting the
14th Amendment uh it says every person
qualified and sub excuse me I keep
flipping the two around article 30 and
every person qualified as the
Constitution provides shall be
considered an inhabitant for the
purposes of electing or being elected
into that office where he dwelleth and
hath his home that's pretty close so
what does that word mean in 1976 the
state legislature did something it
shouldn't have done it posed five yes or
no questions to the voters and the
domicile question comes to life now I
know for sure the the meaning of
domicile because there's a famous case
here in New Hampshire called Newberg
versus Peterson Newberg versus Peterson
the backstory was a a young man born in
New Hampshire in the area of
Dartmouth was um went to vote and he
told the supervisor of the checklist
that when he graduated from school he
was going to move to Hawaii well they
they disallowed him casting his ballot
so he sued in federal court and won
because they had no right cuz he had the
birth right he was born here and there
he was a qualified voter by birth
because of the immigration of
naturalization and the federal court had
to figure out what dwelleth in ha's home
means because domicile doesn't exist
until
1976 so they considered that and the
federal judge said that dwelleth in ha's
home is an old style of English that
means
domicile so why did I tell you that
story because in 1976 they POS five yes
or no questions to the voters question
one was already law the voting age had
already been reduced from 21 to 18 why
is it the lead question e question e
absentee voting was supposed to be
created by this amendment of 1976 which
wasn't true cuz that happened in
1942 question B
and question d one was the doile
question D was changing the month from
January to December as to when we're
going to announce the outcome of the
election those have all those have been
adjudicated already and have been struck
down by the court so why did they go
through all of this trouble to swap the
word inhabitant in doile they told the
voters that if you pass this that we're
now going to focus on domicile instead
of inhabitant and this was the beginning
of the
chaos because they had done one other
thing they had removed five words from
the word citizen of the United States
from the original Law quote being native
born or naturalized citizen of the
United States if you remove the
modifying language in front of the word
citizen of the United States you would
now be saying that you have they they
detailed the manner in which you became
a state citizen this was a big deal
because without it if you're going to
refer to a qualified voter based on his
citizenship status right and you use the
word citizen of the United States that
applies to every all 50 states every
person born in the United States can
move here tomorrow check into a hotel
room take that receipt go register at
the local new town hall because you said
a citizen of the United well that's
every American who's been born or
naturalized because you weren't focusing
on State citizenship so if you're not
going to refer to State citizenship they
started using the word residence and
they started using the word domicile and
both of them only declare one thing that
you live somewhere the word reside
residence or resident don't mean
anything in anyone's dictionary going
back to before the Revolution other than
you live there but State citizenship on
the other hand and here's the key Point
under federal law most people don't know
this
under federal law it's illegal since the
early 1970s to apply a durational
residency requirement in order to cast a
ballot or to register to vote so in
other words the state legislature is
precluded by federal law to say you got
to live here for 30 days can't do that
but here's the hook if you make it State
citizenship the state has its Sovereign
authority to Define who its citizens are
this goes back to the beginning of the
found the beginning of the Republic
under the first immigration
Naturalization Act of 1790 won't bore
you with all the details but from that
point forward the states retained under
their Sovereign Authority Under the 9th
and 10th Amendment the ability to retain
their right to Def to Define who their
citizens are now this was in effect from
1808 all the way to
1973 and then it went away they they n
three years later we get the domile
question and everything's been a chaos
ever since and only thing we've gotten
out of it is billable hours
because it just doesn't get solved and
we keep looking for solutions that don't
and so article 38 of the Bill of Rights
says that the best thing to do is to go
backwards and to look at what was there
before so that is the issue on state
citizenship inhabitant defined now um
bottom of page 10 is my first provision
to inhabitant defined and I'll run
through the list very quickly this court
reaffirmed the definition of the word
inhabitant in the following opinion of
the justices in
1927 same thing here another decision
every person qualified as the
Constitution provides shall be
considered an inhabitant for the
purposes of electing or being elected
into office the state constitution says
the same why do we keep in statute
referring to people as residents and
domicile when the Constitution requires
the use of
inhabitant and with that I need a
okay
e
will reconvene and continue to hear Mr
Richard's testimony um just uh for
context we were on the topic of
citizenship I think this is of uh great
interest to the subcommittee and perhaps
the election law committee at large so
uh please continue and uh
time thank you so much uh page 13 of my
testimony how to become a state citizen
this is the 1808
law and um what's fascinating about this
chapter 49 is that it happened 18 years
after the US Constitution went into
effect so what's important is the
understanding of how both the state
and federal constitutions work together
in this document and so let me go
through it uh this was the original text
um being enacted by the Senate and the
House of Representatives in the general
court convened that every male
inhabitant of each town and Parish with
it with Town Privileges and places
unincorporated the state being a natural
born or naturalized citizen of the
United States that's what I was alluding
to earlier of 21 years of age and
upwards again 1808 women were excluded
and you had to be 21 and and just uh
just to clarify Mr Richard uh the
underline bolded text is your
highlighting of that text it was not in
that original no it's there it's there
to for a special Focus because that is
what was modified by representative
Sanborn House Bill 363 in
1973 he was concerned he must have been
a Soldier he was concerned that he his
children would have um without fixing
what he perceived as a problem that they
would be impacted by being born
abroad and so that's why he wanted the
language change to citizen of the United
States instead of a citizen of the state
thinking he wouldn't have the same
protections but he didn't know the
immigration policy which was if you are
if you are born in the United States
like John McCain or Ted Cruz right and
then you're born of American parents
while deployed for any reason or it
doesn't matter as long as your parents
were were Americans um but anyway that
language was removed being a
natural-born or a naturalized citizen of
the United States when I first read this
I was confused I said if the federal
government under Article 1 Section 8 of
the enumerated powers for the federal
Congress gives them the responsibility
to naturalize people what are they
talking about in a state statute
and then the following chapter gives us
the
answer 21 years of excuse me 21 years of
age and upwards accepting poppers and
persons excused from paying taxes at
their own expense shall have a right at
the annual or other meetings of the
inhabitant of said town and parishes to
vote in the town or Parish where he
dwells and has hath his home there's
that language again that no person shall
be considered an inhabitant in any Town
Parish in the state for the purposes of
voting unless he have resided in such a
place for 6 months or it become a
Freeholder that was common practice to
be holding land and having
resources now here's the here's the part
that I think that we can incorporate
into the legislature now to fix this
problem and I've I think I sent you a
copy of I've consolidating 50 chapters
of election law in the five and a half
pages I did it three years ago and I got
Bill Gardner he loved the idea he says
the only problem Dan is politics
neither party is likely to let you move
this forward but there wasn't an
appetite to fix the problem then and
that's where the affidavit uh ballot
came from I work with various people on
that but this is the solution right here
section two and be it further enacted
that no person not being a citizen of
this state that's very clear of the
state or of the United States shall be
entitled to vote at any town meeting for
the choice of state county or town
offices unless he shall have resided
within the state for 2 years and shall
have made an oath before some justice of
the peace or other person authorized to
administer oath that he will bear faith
and true allegiance to the state of New
Hampshire and to the United States and
will support the Constitutions plural
constitutions thereof provided however
and they repeat themselves that no
person not a citizen of this state of
the United or of the United States shall
be considered qualified to fill any
County or State office the rest of it is
there for your reading pleasure I won't
bore you with any details that was the
point I wanted to make that the the key
is and by the way the 2-year durational
residency in this law in 1808 was in
harmony with the same durational
residency for immigration at the federal
level so they adopted the same policy if
we were to adopt it here it it could be
I know that there's talk about college
kids and instate tuition right when are
you elig and I believe the rule used to
be you had to live here for a year
before you'd be
entitled uh just just to clarify we
actually heard um testimony from Mr
O'Brien earlier today from America votes
that actually the
current um criteria is at the time of
admission and that is their status
throughout their duration at the college
so you know the in state if they're in
state at the time of admission they're
out of state at the time they're out of
state at the time of of admission
regardless of whether or not they change
residency um statewise so um I would say
also I I would say for some people may
may think that this um taking an oath to
and
uh with uh allegiance to the state of
New Hampshire and the United States
might seem archaic and um but that is
exactly the same oath that all
Representatives Senators Governor etc
etc take when we're sworn in so this is
not really an unusual practice or an
outdated practice it's something that
all your elected officials
are um required to do at that um at the
time that they become uh uh accept that
that election result and become an
elected official so
on all right was there were there any
other uh I so I thank you for
highlighting that let me if if I could
just ask a couple of questions yes um
so how so if someone you know how would
you handle this so suppose um we we have
uh what we refer to as snowbirds who uh
live in two places you know uh Southern
climates um I'm not talking
Massachusetts but uh uh Florida and uh
the Carolinas or something like that and
people who are up here portion of the
year if under this scenario if you had
I'm again I I'm asking a hypothetical so
I understand that as well if you have
someone who were to take such an oath to
be a citizen of the State of New
Hampshire and then they decide
to uh well maintaining a residence here
in New Hampshire also obtain a residence
down in
Florida
um at that point I don't see any problem
if they
maintain uh New Hampshire as their
primary residence and they visit they
they take a temporary absence and visit
Florida occasionally but if they
conversely move to Florida and while
maintaining the New Hampshire residence
but then get a driver's
license establish that as their primary
residence for federal tax purposes
for uh you
know uh minimum required distributions
of 401ks Etc you know what how how would
you handle that scenario what what is
there any have you thought about that I
have I have yeah the answer answer is
straightforward and that is that this is
where this this state citizenship
solution is is is really a great idea
and that is that if you you can swap
State citizen with doile the effect of
domicile see doile is is elective
franchise you elect to declare a
domicile when you choose to move right
and by the way back on the oath factor
that was in effect until 1973 in the
last qva before these modifications came
to be that's what was in place is that
you declared that you met the durational
residency requirement to become a
citizen of the
state and so let's walk through it from
my perspective the college kid or the
other person as I said earlier in my
testimony I was born I was naturalized
here so I became a citizen of the state
moved to Texas where I was a resident
but I still had to vote absentee in New
Hampshire because I wasn't a citizen of
Texas the same when you when I went to
the UK for 3 years now college kids same
thing a college kid born in California
has automatic Birthright in the state
where they're born and they are citizens
of the United States under the 14th
Amendment if they move to New Hampshire
the process used to be the state
citizenship route but it got changed to
a domicile and what I found that I I
spoke I spent some time with um with
attorney Brian gold and Bill Gardner
about how they disappointed they they
were with sb3 collapsing on itself and I
thought to myself yeah if anyone had
done their homework they'd have figured
out why are you attaching durational
residency requirement when it's
prohibited by federal law because they
they spent the GOP spent all of its time
trying to Define all the things that
apply to a state citizen but make them
stick to a resident and and it's the
same with um statute 20 in the statutory
construction 21 and 216a
216 commingles inhabitant and Resident
together well how are you going to do
that if the Constitution says you got to
be an inhabitant but the statute says
that an inhabitant or a resident who
establish a
doile well here's here's a little trivia
for you how many times is the word
resident used in the state constitution
once and it's not in the Bill of Rights
it is in contradistinction to the word
inhabitant with the word
reside uh let me let me uh ask a
clarifying question because I want to
make sure I'm sometimes slow on the
uptake so you're saying that in fact
inhabitant is distinguished from
Resident absolutely it has a
constitutional definition and I would
argue in 1976 what was really a foot
with the domicile game was prior to that
it was well understood I have a long
list of the diff definitions of
inhabitant I read a couple of lines the
rest of it is there it's like 30
different places where the word
inhabitant is defined by the
Constitution and what the legislature at
the time didn't like is that voter
qualifications were defined by the
Constitution and not the legislature so
the domicile game became well if we qual
if we use the word domicile someone
establishing a domicile the legislature
gets to Define what those qualifications
are where it shouldn't be imagine your
employees you start a company and you
write an an employment manual on how to
elect more or how to hire more employees
Freudian slip sorry but what happens is
and then all of a sudden the manual that
you wrote on how you want your employees
the qualifications you want for anyone
working for you and now you change it
and now your
employees that's the problem right the
elected class Article 1 Section 8 our
representative body are now deciding who
gets how they reelect themselves that's
what's flawed about that about that line
of of logic but I I digress um did I
answer the question yeah yes I think so
because what you're if I'm uh if I'm
understanding um
there's there's almost an implicit
conflict of interest if we remove the
voter qualifications from the
Constitution and put it into to
the uh rsas right do what the
Constitution doesn't provide if you
study the amount of times the state
constitution has been amended you'll
find in the 19th century from the from
the 18th into the 19th century there
were relatively few changes until we get
to the 20th century I'll give you an
example the Department of Education in
1850 the state legislature proposed 12
amendments to the State Constitution and
of those 12 uh I'll focus on five they
wanted to get rid of the executive
Council that's amendment number one two
and its replace replace it with the
lieutenant governor number three created
a department of railroad number four
create a Department of Education create
a Department of Agriculture and seven
other things they woke up the next
morning and the people said no we're not
giving the state government any more
power because that's what article one
says all power we are constitutional
republic that uses a democratic process
but we've started acting like a
democracy in the last few years where a
majority rule of either party leave
leaves legislation put in place that's
passed on along political lines that is
not in harmony with the
Constitution because that is ultimately
our constraint that is the limiting
governing document in all of
this if that's good I'm going to move on
to the next piece federal law us code
title 8 aliens and nationality I'm going
here to point out help us with the page
you US law defines under uh definitions
1101 the term naturalization means the
conferring the nationality of a state
upon any person after birth by any means
whatsoever back to the state citizenship
point right right understand because
again we have concurrent jurisdiction we
must be mindful that we have a state
constitution and a Federal Constitution
both of them which have effect on the
election
process now State Constitution Article
11 I put this uh I found it fascinating
that it was one sentence in 1784 today
it's a page and a half the first the
first article 11 controlling our
elections in in New Hampshire all
elections ought to be free and every
inhabitant of the state having the
proper qualifications has an equal right
to elect or be elected into office that
was June 2nd 1784 today it's long so I
highlighted the relevant points article
11 and elective franchise all elections
are to be free and here's that word and
every inhabitant not
resident of the state 18 years of age
and upwards she'll have an equal right
to vote in any election that is another
constraint on this on this B on the
committee uh both sub and Committee of
the whole is to please pay attention to
that point it's re it's reaffirming
itself and and then down at the bottom
absentee voting now I testified last
time that in during the Civil War period
in 1863 was the first time the state
legislature
considered uh absentee voting because of
the Civil
War and the Supreme Court said no the
legislature has no authority to
establish any exemption for absentee
voting next World 1921 World War I same
question same problems same people
Supreme Court said we told you 50 years
ago you have no Authority by Statute to
create a new exemption to vote absentee
so that leads to 1942 where they
actually go ahead and do it and that's
part of the record here along the list
of exhibits I've got seven exhibits for
you to review and they're made up of the
original Amendment and the subsequent
changes and um but yeah 1942 so I would
argue and I did argue that if it took an
amendment to the state constitution to
permit the two Provisions that exist
because you be out of town or two that
you're physically disabled I would say
that in 1979 when they created by
Statute a religious
exemption that that was wrong and that's
how the notary certificate went away see
you only had two exemptions you had
physical
disability uh I'm sorry I'm out of town
physically disabled and the notary
certificates right well now if you're
going to add a third exemption now a new
set of instructions for the Secretary of
State came to be and that's where the
defect came to be by Omission because
it's part of the record that I've left
for you is that they that's all they did
and it wasn't the recodification either
it was they recodified all the laws and
the affidavit process stayed with it
like secretary scandin testified to but
that's how they made the notary
certificate go away it wasn't a
thoughtful legislative process and now
has left this
deficiency but let me read you what it
says the general court shall provide by
law for voting by qualified voters I
interpret that as people who are already
registered to vote qualify voters who at
the time of the biannual or state
elections or of the primary elections
therefore or the city elections or the
town elections by official ballot are
absent from the city or town of which
they are in habitants or by who by re or
or or who by reason of physical
disability are unable to vote in person
in the choice of any officer or officers
to be elected upon the question
submitted at such election and then at
the bottom of of article 11 every
inhabitant of the state having the
proper qualifications has the equal
right to be elected into office
repeating article 30 that inhabitant
applies to those who want to vote def
defining those who possess political
rights that's what the word means and
it's defined by the con by the state
supreme court in multiple cases now
closing out qualification Clauses US
Constitution is Article 1 Section 2 the
House of Representatives shall be
composed by members chosen every second
year by the people of the several states
that phrase right there I can tell you
with great certainty what it means the
people of the several States means the
citizens of the several States and that
opinion comes from Dread Scott for those
of you uh in this committee who don't
know the case Dread Scott is a racist
decision a black eye on the US Supreme
Court where they said it only apply the
Constitution only applies to white
people and and so that's why part of
what the 14th amendment was all about
was to solve that problem but either way
that's what it means and the electors
that's why they refer to this as the
qualification clause and the electors in
each state shall have the qualifications
requisite for electors of the most
numerous branch of the state legislature
this is where history is important in
1784 the Senate was the first chamber in
the state government it was not the
second as it is today so you find all of
the election Provisions in the Senate
and not the house when it was inverted
so a lot of people who try to do their
own homework run into an obstacle there
but I wanted to point that out to you so
whatever the ru so basically what they
said was the Senate rules are the rules
for election process and by the way the
same applies for the House of
Representatives so that's why the Senate
rules govern how we elect senators and
US
congressmen any questions on that did I
lus you it's a
lot no okay all right and then no sh no
person shall be a representative who
shall have attained the age of 35 and
been seven years a citizen of the United
States
and who shall not when elected be an
inhabitant in other words you can't have
you can't hold political office in two
places so you can't be a member of the
House of Representatives here and be a
us Congressman at the same
time Article 1 Section 4 and this is a
big deal times places in manner of
holding elections for senators and
representatives shall be prescribed in
each state by the legislature thereof
this is where the ballot law commission
gets into trouble I know I'm off track
but this is why it can't make law it
can't make rules and regulations for an
alternate method of counting other than
that which the legislature has
prescribed and this is reaffirmed by
more V Harper but that's the point here
I also included remember I told you
earlier durational residency that's 52
us code
10,502 residency requirement for voting
no citizen of the United States who is
otherwise qualified to vote in any
election for President vice president
shall be denied the right to vote for
electors of the president and vice
president or president vice president in
such election because of failure of such
citizen to comply with any durational
residency requirement of such state
state or political subdivision again
this body and the legislature can't say
you got to live here for x amount of
time if it impedes on your right to vote
you can do it for citizenship you can
Define that you've got to live here for
x amount of time before we're going to
allow you to become a state citizen
because that carries forward under the
common law under Article 90 but for for
this for this case that that's what it's
talking about now lastly here uh voting
rights uh
10,101 and this is what's wrong with the
affidavit problem as we look at it today
no person acting under color of law for
those who are not lawyers that's the
illusion of government Authority okay
operating under color of Law and
determining whether any individuals
qualified under state laws or law to
vote in any election apply any standard
practice or procedure different from the
standards practices or procedures
applied under such law or laws to other
individuals within the same County
Parish or similar political subdivision
who have been found by state officials
to be qualified to vote that's the big
that's the big Federal prohibition right
that you can't have two different sets
of rules in the same town or voting
district Danville just had a case go to
this rock Rockingham County Superior
Court there was a challenge where the
moderator wanted to do a separate count
to verify his certification to run
parallel to the machine count and the
state supreme court upheld this not the
Supreme Court the Rockingham Court
upheld as principal and said that's
right if your town chooses to use a
machine you got to use a machine you
can't do both can't be hand counting and
machine counting at the same time
because you have two different ways of
doing it so that's the recent decision
out of our Superior Court out of the
Danville decision and and that brought
forward um not to not to get too
sidetracked onto the Danville case but
was that a uh um because we had the the
larger committee heard some testimony
about a similar subject recently and
were they trying were they doing that in
parallel or were they that's what they
were trying to do and I believe that is
their testimony and the court in my
opinion I read the decision they were
right on their conclusions but they got
to it in in my opinion a wrong way to
get there but either way they still
we're still of the same mind and that is
that you have to have and again back to
what were they doing to the freed slaves
back in the day they were applying
different practices procedures and
policies to disenfranchise them and so
this carries forward and finally uh
criminal pen another part of the
criminal penalties and this deals with
the lack of certifying the absentee
ballots knowing criminal penalties
number two knowingly and willfully
deprives defrauds or attempts to deprive
or defraud the residents of the state of
a fair and impartially conducted
election process by a the procurement or
submission of voter registration
applications that are known by the
persons to be materially false
fictitious or fraudulent under the laws
of the state in which the election is
held or B the procurement casting or
tabulation of ballots that are known by
the person to be materially false
fictitious or fraudulent under the laws
of the state in which the election is
held these Federal issues the state
hasn't touched and doesn't want to touch
because they lose so they have not
answered so they've avoided this until
secretary scanland opened that door but
either way um that's what I'm arguing in
my case and that they and look my
position is simple
the secretary of state has the benefit
of legal counsel how do you do this
wrong how do you not know that there's a
problem there's an affidavit problem and
you write a new solution with an
election procedure
manual and so that's something that you
guys will have to take up at your own at
your own speed that's your that's your
business and I also there's another
document I'm not going to read it to you
now the bottom here on um it's header
criminal interference with State and
Federal elections when the state supreme
court remanded my case back to the trial
court the trial judge because they
didn't address the equal protection
arguments that I had raised went ahead
and gave the state defendants a a
seventh bite at the Apple to brief the
equal protection issues and when they
did so I pointed out that you're
violating federal law that's where my
allegation of criminal interference and
I'll let you read that but that is now
before the Rockingham County Court were
waiting on uh we're waiting on that that
decision to move forward to a um a uh
scheduling conference
so very good um thank so representative
Lane you have a
question I just want to make sure that I
understand the state citizenship piece
yes versus the uh res I know it's not
called res domicile requirement the
length of the years yes so I just want
to make sure
that were you suggesting that you could
perhaps get around that requirement by
putting it in the requirement of State
citizenship that you had to live here
durational residency under the
sovereignty of the State under the 9th
and 10th Amendment and the original
naturalization law still has that
authority to do so they can say you need
to live here for 30 days 60 days a year
in order to become a citizen of the
state if you use doile or residency as
qualifying language if you're going to
write that into your statute you cannot
you cannot use a durational residency
test under the federal law that that's
why I was asking the question I just
wanted to make sure IOD so where in I
and I don't know this where do are the
requirements to be a New Hampshire
citizen laid out in our statute chapter
49 that I read to you earlier the
original 1808 law
and the I gave you the Consolidated
updated version to include women and the
voting age down to 18 and I can put it
all together and in the definitions
chapter which is key in my work that I
sent you uh has all the proper
definitions written there based on the
historical context I I have one more
question um I just have question related
to that answer no no I just want to make
representative
Lane um on page 10 when you were reading
the uh down towards the bottom the
citizens of each state shall be entitled
to all privileges and
immunities did you say that the citizens
of the several states does not include
because it says does include well the
privileges and immunities clause
involves all citizens of the several
States so that is your right to travel
and it does not include elections
there's no okay so the word not is it's
left out I think in what I'm reading and
I may have I may have goofed in a hurry
to get this all done so please forgive
me if there's no I just want to make
sure I heard you correctly okay thank
you you're welcome that's it and the
only other thing that I had go ahead uh
representative Newsome has a question
I'd like to entertain his question um
you when um representative Lane asked
you about the statute to become a state
citizen yes you referred to the law in
1808 that you handed out yes um are you
aware that that Act was repealed less
than 6 months later yes is there a
current definition yes in what section
would that be in today's rsas let me
back up and re restate my answer thank
you it existed from 1808 till
1973 and in
1973 that was removed so the process the
qva was the last evidence that was in
the 1950s in the
1950s uh chapter 50 and so on forget
forgive me on the numbers but whatever
came from the 1950s lasted until the 70s
and that's where that language went away
about being a citizen of the state
because now we're referring to
citizenship as National citizenship by
by removing those words native born or
naturalized so you're right it doesn't
exist in statutes today okay so if we
were to to go down that route and use
that we would then need to reinstate
that as part of it the old policy
correct yes yes um and sorry one more
follow up on this um do any other states
use a state citizenship standard Curr I
haven't cross referenced anyone
currently and I don't think they do okay
thank you and and I believe that the the
the start of all of this starts in a in
Tennessee there was a um a law professor
who moved to Tennessee he was taking a
job at the University there and they had
already changed their language to
residency as a prerequisite and so he
went to register and was denied the
right to vote and he sued and won it
made it all the way I think to the
federal courts and he said hey I'm a new
Resident why does an old resident why am
I being disenfranchised because why are
you treating me differently we're still
focusing on the word resident and word
resident based on State Statute gets
applied based on what the legislature
has decided so that's the problem that's
where that's where all of this really
stems from is we stopped focusing on
state citizens ship and from that point
on if we're not going to refer to
someone as a state citizen we're left
with only two other words residency or
domicile and that's what we're using
now and just uh
so and no other are there other states
that are using this domicile aspect do
you know about that I believe almost all
of them are okay all of them are because
again if we're not and I think that this
should be a 50 f a 50-state solution not
just one state because if we finally get
to that my solution to anyone who is
here temporarily going to school or
otherwise is you still get the vote
absentee and we do need to do a better
job at making sure that they have those
Provisions especially for our citizens
who are deployed elsewhere because
that's where absentee voting really came
to be in the first place is to address
deployed veterans and those supporting
effort uh representative vernham thank
you um so
going back to pre is it 1973 or 1976 I'm
kind of uh there's three events 77 7 79
77 76 and 73 which one so 73 I believe
is the last time it was or that's the
year ex change for the state citizenship
correct okay so um was it before that
were um voters required to show a state
citizenship document is there a
documentation they would have shown to
vote the law the the 1808 Law chapter 49
ultimately is modified to the point that
by the time that we see the last
evidence of State
citizenship is uh at that period of time
and they did so um lost my
way 73 on the state citizenship oh the
qva qva there it is the qva so the qva
that we have today the qualified voter
affid David was the the something to the
effect that that you swear to the fact
that you have met the durational
residency requirement to become a
citizen of the state and that went away
when that went away was all part of
these changes in the 70s in that way we
were now focused on doile and residency
as the focal point for legislation
establishing that as the basis and I
I've also attached in these exhibits
I've also given you the um the voters
guides and I just have a followup do you
what new uh State residents would have
to do in order to vote say they moved um
you know previous to 1973 moved to New
Hampshire for voting they would swear at
this the same process or was there do
you know if there's a was a different
process with new people moving into New
Hampshire from what period are you
asking me about the period when it was
in effect prior to 1973 what was the
process for them to vote if they were
new I don't want to say residents but
new citizens of New Hampshire they
wouldn't become a citizen until they had
met the durational residency requirement
established by the legislature to be a
state Citizen and once that went away
now you're dealing with the federal law
on durational residency for voting you
can't go there for voting if you go
okay you're
welcome all right I think uh I got one
more thing for you okay federal law and
I'll wrap up real quick very quickly you
asked me about the Brewin decision so
what's happened is the US Supreme Court
in the in the Second Amendment case took
on uh this Perpetual problem of the
Second Amendment and what they've done
that's radically changed the landscape
is they I know that the attorneys will
get this they've abolished means ands
scrutiny means and scrutiny for a
Layman's perspective is that the courts
for the last 60 70 years have been
applying a balancing test when they
examine any proposed legislation that is
being uh there's an allegation that it
infringes upon any of the rights so the
second amendment's been back and forth
and what the Supreme Court said look why
do we treat the Second Amendment
different than the first amendment than
the confrontation clause in the sixth
amendment and or uh the freedom of
religion so it address four other issues
and it said look from now on we're
abolishing means and scrutiny from which
is three different levels of of a
balancing test in other words the court
the judge would say all right we have
the Bill of Rights here but we have the
public interest here and so how much
should anyone tolerate public policy
infringing upon your rights and so they
said you can't do this anymore from now
on when ever a a legislative act
infringes upon any of the enumerated
rights the burden of proof shifts from
the go from the people to the government
to prove their statutory scheme was
permissible when the Bill of Rights was
written let me give you an example in
1791 there was a militia Act and the
militia act required that all
able-bodied men had to carry a musket
Gunpowder and Lead and that they had to
be 18 years of age so today it would be
permissible for the state legislature to
say open carry of firearms you got to be
18 why because they could point to a
historical analogy of going back in time
and saying in 1791 it was permissible to
restrict gun ownership in public to
people who are 18 and so this is now
morphed into the examination of all of
our rights and uh I also quoted another
case that just came down this summer
which is the NAACP case um the NAACP of
South Carolina accused the South
Carolina legislature of being racist
they accused the whole body of being
racist Clarence Thomas writes a
concurring opinion uh with the majority
joining the majority that now ties the
federal elections clause and the Second
Amendment case of bruan heler and so
there wasn't that bridge as the
attorneys will tell you is that in order
to have precedent you have to have a
case that moves into the court so right
now those Second Amendment cases that
I've just talked about those Federal
decisions that decision now creates a
bridge in my opinion that didn't exist
because that would only apply to the
federal Bill of Rights it wouldn't apply
to the state because it's not State case
law and it's not a state issue even
though there may be a correlating event
but either way that's the point that
they made so from now on when we look at
dealing with those issues and again it's
because election law is current
jurisdiction with both the state and
federal Constitution so I believe and
those documents by the way are what I
called late authorities the Supreme
Court has a rule because it takes such a
long time to go through the process they
have a rule that permits that any
decisions of scotus or of our state
supreme court or of the legislature that
comes down the pike that they can be
added as a l Authority and I did submit
three of them and I've given you two and
that will lay out the boundaries at your
own leisure to understand what those
Federal boundaries are as to how to
legislate here in New Hampshire what are
those constraints like I said earlier
you're not the two constraints are your
state and federal Constitution other
than that you're unlimited at your
problem solving I know some people don't
true all right with that I will thank
you uh for your testimony uh and for um
I'm sure you could have talked for hours
more so I I appreciate this all lives in
my head just so you know I'm sure I I'm
sure that's an interesting place as well
so right so um uh thank you very much um
that concludes uh our Our Testimony
today we're not taking anything other
there are some matters that we do need
to
discuss
um uh
just uh
some Logistics here I'm sure please
forgive me for any this was not proofed
and if you need it redone I'd be glad to
resubmit it and if there's any mistakes
or further questions don't hesitate to
reach out to me can I actually just get
another copy of the packet that you gave
yes for filing purposes than I know
representative weary has the best copy I
think I gave you a good one but if you
focus on his and some of this got broken
down that's what delayed me at The Print
Shop I was working with someone who was
less than skilled
I I just I think it would be good to
have it for the record as well just have
a copy absolutely I've already marked up
mine so it's not gonna be good okay
um I will I will hang so I have that
here and I
will
um I will figure out a way to make sure
we get copies of
this upstairs yeah and they can make
okay thank you all for your time it's
been a pleasure to sit down with you I
uh I'm very very grateful and
appreciative for this opportunity so
thank you again thank you go ahead and
hit that button again thank you all
right so um just a couple of matters of
house cleaning um representative Lane
did have some follow-up questions to one
of the memos that Mr Allen provided to
us I have uh forwarded that email to Mr
Allen and he will respond in uh Due Time
according with his excellent responses
as always so we appreciate that we
appreciate all the research that he's
been doing um on behalf of the
subcommittee um I think also um just I
want to reiterate something I said at
the beginning uh we had on the public
notice that house bill 608 was would be
part of today's working session but um
due to some errors that had been already
exec and so um we are not doing any
action on that today whatsoever Al
though we did hear some related um just
what's
that
um to be honest I I computer whz wait so
wait it's it's requiring moderators to
inspect absentee badat for Davids for
full
execution I I I honestly can't remember
I'm sorry we've we've had 75 bills this
year in election law and so it's keeping
I've got kind of not alphabet soup but
number soup in my brain right now so
um respect
I've
got I have it as
calendar all right so so I believe I itl
was
uh uh the outcome of 608 and that's
that's why this committee is not uh
subcommittee is not working on it so I
just want to that was part of the um
opening discussion or opening points and
I just wanted to reiterate that to make
sure that that was
understood
um we are on a uh pretty aggressive
timeline because I think crossover day
is the
27th whatever that th last Thursday in
March is hang on just a
second um
let me just check
that uh yeah 27th so and everyone saw
the note that we might be meeting for a
house session on the 26 as well just
keep that in mind um yes of course so I
wanted
to yes we are
um I wanted to just say um I I will be
attempting to uh
uh put together a report over the next
several
days
um
and uh as soon as I
am done with that I will get it to this
committee my my
done
um yeah it's going to have to be soon so
to get it done um early next week so
that we may discuss it as best we can on
the
14th um that still gives us a little
time we may not we we're not obligated
to
make um actions on every bill because
the larger committee can do that
independent of us and so they're not the
larger committee is certainly not
beholden to the subcommittee it's the
opposite so um as proofed by HB 608 and
so
um we may not we may not take action on
every bill that that we've identified as
being before this subcommittee but I
will try
to um to some degree acknowledge each
bill that was originally listed and say
what you know what was the you know
aspect that was gerine to the
subcommittee's uh interests
I'll try to include that in the report
um and my my goal is again to try and
get this to the committee by the
11th at least a a
fairly decent draft and then um we will
have further discussion on the 14th and
the minority party is always welcome to
submit a minority version to as an
addendum to the
um uh report so and we will
include
uh Mr Allen's research
memos as well
as um this testimony if I have time I
will also try and capture a few of the
salent points of testimony from um the
various people that we've heard speak
which includes uh secretary scanland
deputy secretary
Hennessy um Mr Clement totz
from um the ACLU Mr O'Brien from uh on
behalf of America votes and um of course
Mr Richard so I I will not try to
summarize Mr Richard's testimony but of
course he h he has his own summary so
we'll we'll include that and and
um uh and those will be a you know
addendums or attachments to the report
as
necessary
um so that those are the you know my my
sort of main thoughts I want to discuss
um actions or or whether or not we need
to take any actions on on the uh
remaining bills within the
subcommittee um and I want to discuss
the aspects of the
report and
um it any other comments I welcome uh
comments or responses to what I've just
said M representative C I was just uh
wondering what were we going to try to
come up with recommendations for
correcting the bills that are in front
of us uh or just try to
summarize the
areas um and whether or not we should be
U coming up with a overall all solution
possibly as legislation for next
year I uh that's an excellent question I
I do think it is uh yes all of the above
um so I think if if we have
opportunities to do something in the
short term I think we certainly want to
do that if we want to take a longer term
solution and I use this merely as an
example you know citizenship within New
Hampshire that that that uh is certainly
not something you know that would
involve uh cacr it would involve changes
to the rsas it would in it would require
a comprehensive approach and it would
require a lot of coordination
between um you know our uh Secretary of
State um the uh people on the other side
of the wall
and and the attorney general for certain
yes thank you thank you very much thank
you for on behalf of all the lawyers yes
uh thank thank you very much so um we we
certainly need to
uh keep that in mind for any long-term
Solutions so I don't think
that what this committee could do is
comment perhaps uh in the report on
possible long-term
Solutions and you know really
just make notes of what I said I think
you know then it is up to the chair or
or individuals if the it'll be up to the
chair of the election law committee if
he then wishes
to form a a subcommittee to further
review the that
aspect um you know pursuant to what was
done last year for the uh Finance
aspects so I think you know it's really
would be up to Chairman Barry at that
point and but but it's c within the
purview and the mission statement of the
oh I forgot to read the mission
statement uh earlier but it's within the
perview of this subcommittee to make
those sort of recommendations I think if
there is any short-term long
short-term recommendations those should
be with you know proposals to changes to
the
RSA that we or the bills that amendments
to the bills that we have before so if
anyone has thoughts along those lines
um let me know
um yeah representative Lane um I'm gonna
I'll give uh representative
Nome credit for this but when we were
talking um in the break one thought we
had because we've got all this
information and we're missing the
Attorney General's information because
they can't come in and I just think
that's really critical when we make our
recommendations so you suggested maybe
we retain a lot of these bills or retain
some of them with the idea that we would
be because some of them are kind of on
the same topic so do we
retain but I it because that's kind of
what we did in the campaign Finance one
is that then we spent the summer God
forbid I'm sorry everybody but spent the
summer and fall working on those bills
and so that they were able to come in
with amendments and really thought out
and worked on and very comprehensive and
and because this is a big issue big
issues here and I I hate to feel rushed
and that's you know and I we learned a
lot today I think around the absentee
voting piece and I know that and I I'm
not even sure if any of these bills
really touch on that custody piece that
we have I I don't recall but anyway that
that would be my and I think just along
those lines and I think representative
CU you had kind of touched on that idea
about retaining some of these as well um
but especially in consideration of the
ACLU case and Mr Richard's case that I'd
hate to kind of go out
and do a couple rsas now and then have
the legal framework with with which in W
within which we need to act kind of
pulled the rug out from under us and be
in the same exact
area next
year although I know it's it's always a
moving battle there'll always be court
cases but I think we may want to let the
dust settle from last
year's
amendments and and I think retaining
would give us that opportunity to let
that let that dust settle take a
holistic approach to all of this because
I think from my point of view while the
and correct me if I'm wrong with the
mission kind of started out as a
non-resident voting concept but I think
a lot of what we've talked about and
heard and learned is that it really is
coming down to two classes of Voters and
we need to kind of bring everything in a
line to one
class and I think that I I think it kind
of misses the original intent but I
think it was a the right path to go on
um and I think that that retaining
some all almost I I don't have an idea
yet on which ones to kind of keep around
for that but to then have it as a study
to really get a
holistic approach for
everything uh might be just as a
suggestion uh thank you for that
representative Newsome I think um my so
first of all um we have no power to
retain U but but the but but we can make
that a recommendation so um I need so I
I just wanted to clarify in case anyone
listening uh I have no illusions of
power I just want people to understand
that so um uh but I I do think you know
I do think that there are some you know
obviously some merits to that we want to
think through this and we we want
[Music]
to I think we want to improve things but
we also uh don't want to create a lot of
double work where we're fixing something
this year and then fixing it again next
year and then the following year if we
all are elected um fixing it one more
time or Cho yeah or choose choose to
continue to uh inflict this upon
ourselves so
um representative C I was just thinking
that one of the things that we probably
should um uh talk about is an idea
because that's one of the things that
seems to be more urgent than than a lot
of other things and I thought it was
interesting uh what the gentleman from
ACLU was speaking about in particular if
a person doesn't drive he doesn't need a
driver's license and in fact if if
there's no other issue he doesn't need
any kind of photo ID on on
him and it's not a requirement to live
in the state to have an
ID but he still should be allowed to
that's yeah and and um right and there
is a there is a non-driver
identification that the DMV provides I
think we you know that is something that
is a current capability we are not if if
we pursue that for identification
purposes for those people who are not
driving that is
not we're not asking for the DMV to take
on a new capacity it's something they
currently do I think um and that has
some merits to consider but um so you
have followup Mr represent as a followup
on that uh it may be that we might want
to specify a certain situation
where the fee for getting the non-
waved yes I I I think that's that's that
makes sense we we certainly do not want
um any perception of that to be a you
know the proverbial pull tax or anything
um the the key is that no voter is
overly burdened I think that's certainly
what I have seen from the uh court cases
that we've been uh that have been
any the comment representative Lane I
was just gonna say I think that that
that might be the kind of in the report
when it comes out is that we kind of
look at the
because we heard that for purposes of
just identifying who you are you know
any kind of picture that shows that you
are who you are may be acceptable but it
may be different in different
circumstances and so um and that might
be something that comes out of the
report and we could maybe amend those
statutes and kind of do those if we want
if not retain them I mean I'm not in um
I had another thought but I don't
remember um because I'm I'm getting
really tired we had an interesting
meeting earlier
today I I think I'm about to hit the
wall so okay all right well I I resp
representative C you mentioned one word
that just caught my ear was overburdened
and I just thought about people standing
in lines because last night I stood in
line for over half an hour to vote at my
school district meeting and it was
interesting because
uh everybody in the long line was from
my town ofden everybody else they were
going out and saying anybody from any of
the other towns there's no line at your
station wow wow okay that's uh yeah I
mean that is something that uh election
law and the municipalities certainly
have to wrestle with we do not want long
lines and our voters to be burdened by
that aspect and we need to really uh but
that's not merely an election law
problem election law committee problem
it is a problem for the Ws to consider
um let me go around
um uh and ask for any final comments um
representative Nome not at this time
Burnham I um am over welmed with some
knowledge so that is my comment for
today thank you very much representative
C I think my brain's
full and representative blade I'll I'll
join that course I will let you know
that um at the request of the of our
chair I went through um 385 which was my
bill that was undoing
1569 and um I found uh a couple of
things that should have been omitted and
I've put in to OS to do an amendment um
but I do have copies of what I sent to
them so that y'all could see you know
what I was doing and what I was change
what I Chang so I have those and um I
think yes that would be it okay well
thank you very much I will um as I said
I will
try I will try my best to have
uh some sort of decent report for
people's review early next week um early
meaning you know kind of at the latest
close of business on Tuesday or maybe
end of day on Tuesday we'll we'll see um
how successful I am at writing and um
then we'll certainly plan on meeting on
the
14th
I um we will discuss on
uh may maybe if if um we could just have
some offline
discussions on Tuesday about your
availability the following week in case
we need to
do um a quick meeting or two uh just to
if nothing else to refine the report or
to um if we feel that there is an RSA
that we want to amend what to do there
so
um with that it that I will uh gavel the
meeting closed we only went till 4:30
that what a it's the efficiency of This
Crew here so I appreciate that thank you
so much and everyone have a wonderful
weekend